[Musique]
je tenais d'abord à préciser les propos
que j'ai pu avoir une interview de
france inter est pas vraiment une
interview mais des propos qui ont été
sortis du contexte et je tenais parce
que je sais que certains d'entre vous
ont été vexés ont été choqués par les
propos qui ont été les miens et je
tenais à préciser le contexte dans
lesquels je les ai prononcés
j'ai ressenti un moment un acharnement
médiatique un acharnement politique et
j'ai eu l'impression qu'un certain
nombre de personnes ont pu se servir des
institutions notre pays à des fins
politiques et médiatiques
j'ai servi les institutions de mon pays
depuis l'âge de 18 ans en intégrant la
réserve opérationnelle de la gendarmerie
nationale j'ai toujours défendu les
institutions j'ai toujours respecté les
institutions et j'ai été élevé dans le
respect de ses institutions et je tenais
à vous dire que j'ai un profond respect
pour le cdh 1 j'ai un profond respect
pour les sénateurs et mon propos c'était
celui de d'avoir l'impression d'être
instrumentalisée à des fins politiques
il ya une chose sur laquelle je voudrais
revenir j'ai été bien élevé et j'ai un
profond regret pour le propos que j'ai
pu avoir à votre encontre
monsieur le président parce que en
quelles que soient les circonstances
quelle que soit la pression on s'en
prend pas aux hommes et j'ai le regret
d'avoir eu les propos qui ont été les
miens à votre encontre
pour le reste je voulais vous assurer de
mon respect total de l'institution des
institutions du sénat et des sénateurs
et vous présenter mes excuses à monsieur
le président bas en ce qui concerne les
propos que j'ai pu avoir ce qu'on
n'attaque pas les hommes
voilà les quatre missions qui m'incombe
et il y en a une cinquième cape a été
dit je vous dirai à la fin la première
c'est l'organisation des déplacements
nationaux c'est à dire quand le
président se déplace
vous faites un certain nombre de
réunions préalables vous fait un certain
nombre de préparatoire on appelle ça de
déplacement en préparatoire vous allez
avec le préfet et son directeur de
cabinet le directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique
ça ce sont les locaux qui vous accueille
et vous partez avec un certain nombre de
personnes de l'elysée qui sont en charge
des services à l'elysée vous avez
l'intendant parce qu'il risque d'y avoir
un dîner un cocktail vous avez le
service de presse vous avez le chef du
gspr vous avez le protocole quand il ya
des personnalités étrangères
et vous votre rôle parce que vous êtes à
un niveau s'il faut bien préciser aussi
que qu'est-ce que c'est la chefferie de
cabinet c'est assez flou pour les gens
et je le conçois à l'elysée il ya deux
types de il ya le cabinet politique qui
avec les conseillers les chargés de
mission et vous avez les services qui
sont dans la mise en oeuvre de ce qui a
été décidé au point de vue politique
donc celui qui a autorité sur l'autre
c'est le politique qui a autorité sur
les services jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est pas l'intendant qui va décider
s'il va faire 30 repas ou 80 repas il
fait en fonction de ce qui a été décidé
politiquement par le conseiller en
charge
si demain vous avez un cocktail sur la
thématique agriculture par exemple à
l'elysée dans lequel le président
souhaite inviter un certain nombre de
responsables syndicaux de responsables
agricoles etc
il va vous dire voilà on va faire
quelque chose avec un un dîner un
cocktail vous allez recevoir la consigne
politique du haut du conseiller en
charge de l'agriculture et ensuite vous
allez mener une réunion avec les
différents services et il y aura le
commandement
terre il y aura le cuisinier et or à
l'intendant y aura le service de presse
et vous allez leur dire voilà ce qui a
été décidé
ça c'est le rôle de la chefferie de
cabinet c'est le coeur du réacteur en
terme de logistique et d'organisation et
je vais répondre à la question monsieur
je vais répondre mais il faut comprendre
le contexte est donc vous animer une
réunion dans laquelle il ya plusieurs
personnes et vouloir expliquer voilà ce
qui attend attendu de vous il va y avoir
80 personnes donc il faut prévoir 80
repas monsieur le commandant militaire
en général il va y avoir 80 personnes
qui vont arriver le au mieux par le 55
où vous allez décider par un autre
endroit parce que voulait pas que ça
soit filmé et peu importe
est ce que au moment où je parle au
général je suis dans une fonction de
sécurité au même titre que quand je
parle à l'intendant au chef cuisinier je
suis pas cuisinier moi même ni super
intendant de l'elysée donc quand vous
êtes dans des fonctions la chefferie de
cabinet dans des fonctions transverses
vous êtes dans des fonctions où vous
êtes amené à parler et au chef du gspr
et aux commandants militaires et vous
êtes là pour donner le but à atteindre
les moyens employés par le commandant
militaire les moyens employés par le
chef du j'espère c'est pas vous qui
j'explique par soit un déplacement au
colonel lavergne qui est maintenant en
général tu dois mettre des barrières ici
ou quatre là bas c'est pas ça mon but
c'est de lui dire voilà l'idée c'est
qu'on fasse une arrivée propre parce que
vous êtes une sorte de metteur en scène
vous êtes une sorte de chef d'orchestre
vous êtes sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet le rôle du chef de cabinet et de
la chefferie de cabinet il est très
clair c'est l'organisation générale la
coordination générale il est le chef
d'orchestre des déplacements et des
événements du palais et il est également
le metteur en scène
si je peux me permettre de parler ainsi
et pour être prêt pondre manière très
claire j'avais quatre missions à
l'elysée la première mission est l
organisation des déplacements nationaux
dans le cadre de ce que je viens de vous
expliquer la force que vous en aviez
déjà connaissance il est l organisation
d événements au palais dans le cadre de
ce que je viens de vous expliquer la
également dont vous avez connaissance il
était le cadre l'organisation et je vais
employer le terme parce que ce qu'on
appelle les déplacements privés du
président de la république je pourrais
m'en expliquer si vous avez des
questions là-dessus
et il était dans une tasse dans une
tâche pardon qu'on a appelée
coordination des services de sécurité la
coordination des services de sécurité je
pense vous avoir expliqué le par mon
parcours ça que j'ai une petite
connaissance du domaine de la sécurité
il consistait pas à être le chef de la
sécurité de l'elysée il consistait à
conduire un certain nombre de réunions
de réflexion souvent si vous prenez le
colonel lavergne qui est maintenant
général qui a besoin de 12 voitures
supplémentaires par exemple pour son
parc automobile
s'il n'a pas un appui politique si le
cabinet n'aide pas c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne c'est le cabinet ne l'aide
pas il pourra aller demander 12 voitures
au ministère de l'intérieur
il sera tout seul face au ministère de
l'intérieur et c'est souvent ce qui se
passe donc par exemple j'avais en charge
le renouvellement du parc automobile de
l'elysée parce qu'à un moment vous êtes
vous fait des réunions à un autre niveau
que deux chefs de service administration
centrale vous faites une réunion un
niveau cabinet c'est à dire le cabinet
du président de la république saisi le
cabinet du ministre l'intérieur parce
qu'il ya besoin de moyens
supplémentaires
voilà c'était c'était paint pour pour
répondre très précisément ce n'était pas
une fonction opérationnelle de sécurité
c'était une fonction administrative
je voulais vous demander quel était
votre fonction par rapport aux
déplacements privés du président de la
république
ceux ci étaient donc que votre fonction
si j'entends bien ce que vous dites ne
relevait pas de la sécurité ou de la
police
en conséquence vous n'étiez pas armés
alors pour être très précis sur
l'histoire du port d'armes j'ai entendu
absolument tout et je sais que c'est pas
quelque chose d'habituel
ça peut poser question c'est un j'ai
fait une demande à titre personnel
d'autorisation de port d'armes pour des
motifs de défense et de sécurité
personnelle parce que quand vous êtes
dans des fonctions à la présidence de la
république ou pendant la campagne
présidentielle vous êtes exposés vous
même et on est tout sauf un jeu qu'à moi
de mon point de vue on est exposé on
passe dans les médias
vous êtes identifié quand vous habitez
dans le même endroit depuis huit ans il
peut vous arriver quelque chose donc
j'ai fait une demande pour ma sécurité
personnelle je crois savoir qu un nombre
important de personnes ayant travaillé à
l'elysée se sont déjà vus délivrer des
autorisations de port d'armes
je pense par exemple je vais citer son
nom j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra pas
mais monsieur michel charasse lorsqu'il
était collaborateur de françois
mitterrand il disposait d'une
autorisation de port d'armes est ce que
monsieur michel charasse était le garde
du corps de françois mitterrand je ne le
crois pas un certain nombre d'autres
sous la présidence chirac par exemple il
y a eu des collaborateurs du président
qui ont pu disposer d'une autorisation
de port d'armes
il ya un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui dispose d'une
autorisation de port d'armes
ça fait pas deux des gardes du corps des
autres parlementaires et tout ça pour
vous dire que une autorisation de port
d'armes c'est quelque chose de très rare
le ministère de l'intérieur les délivre
au compte gouttes en l'occurrence il ya
eu un refus mais pour des motifs
administratifs
parce que la demande la deuxième demande
de port d'armes au moment où je rentre
en fonctions à l'elysée
elle est basée administrativement sur
une première demande donc sont les
fonctions de directeur de la sûreté de
la sécurité dans marche donc ses juges
est pas recevable par la dlp agit c'est
ce que a expliqué en substance ce
stéphane fratacci c'est que la dlp âge
il juge que comme j'ai pas renouveler
une port d'armes en ma qualité de
collaborateur du président la république
ils disent non sur le principe ce qui
est normal ce que doit y avoir un
dossier administratif car et complète
c'est ce qui veut pas dire qu'il a pas
de menace et je rentrerai pas dans les
détails
voilà messieurs
savidan se faire juste un petit instant
fait excuser vous en prie chaque
président fait monsieur benalla nous
pouvons tout entendre mais il y a une
réalité ce sont les visas les attendus
de la décision du préfet de police
elle elle ne dit pas monsieur benalla
pour sa sécurité personnelle a demandé
un port d'armes
et comme il a les qualifications
nécessaires de lui accordons elle dit
monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police dans le cadre de son
action de coordination de la sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr
alors il a bien fallu que la demande
comporte une description de cette
fonction de police pour que le préfet de
police qui n'invente rien puis s'y
référer et d'autre part je laisse de
côté les allégations que vous avez pu
avancer sur des personnes qui auraient
eu des permis de port d'armes ou
d'autres peut-être à l'elysée qui en
aurait aujourd'hui
mais convenez tout de même qu' il ne
suffit pas d'être collaborateurs du
président de la république pour se
trouver dans une insécurité tels que
cela justifie une demande de port
d'armes
je veux juste relever ces points donc je
vous demande très simplement de
m'expliquer pourquoi au préfet de police
on a dit une chose et pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous dites une autre chose
alors encore de manière très précise
je n'ai pas rédigé mon arrêté
d'autorisation de port d'armes cet
arrêté a été rédigé par un service qui
s'appelle la direction de la police
générale et qui a essayé de faire
rentrer mon cas qui n'est pas un cas
conformes dans les clous d'ailleurs il
est très imprécis sur mes fonctions
parce qu'ils expliquent la coordination
entre les forces militaires et le j
espere les forces militaires je ne sais
pas ce que c'est moi je pense que c'est
le commandement militaire du palais
puisque vous nous avez expliqué vous
même cette fonction de coordination des
services de sécurité monsieur loches
nous l'a révélée alors qu'elle ne nous
avait pas été précisée dans nos
premières auditions
et qui dit vous dites il comportait la
coordination du commandement militaire
du palais et du gspr tout à fait et donc
pour répondre précisément je sais pas ce
que le seul interlocuteur que j'ai eu
sur cette autorisation de port d'armes
c'est patrick strzoda qui est dit on va
faire les choses dans les règles et on a
fait les choses dans les règles
il a saisi la préfecture de police de
l'étude du dossier
ensuite qu'une administration prennent
des considérants je crois d'ailleurs qui
à la considérant sur la menace
terroriste qui est précisées dans
l'arrêté que personne ne dit et assure
un certain nombre de menaces
elle est précisé dans un alinéa de
l'arrêter et donc c'est pas forcément
mes fonctions de collaborateurs du
président a plus que c'est qu'il y avait
d'autres menaces dans lequel je ne
rentrerai pas dans le détail mais c'est
précisé sur cet arrêté patrick strzoda
n'est dictée en rien s'est arrêté aux
services de la direction de la police
générale parce que je croirais patrick
strzoda dit voilà il ya alexandre qui
est dans cette situation là qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
est ce que pouvaient le faire ce que
vous pouvez pas le faire et la
préfecture de police a répondu
favorablement et des gens qui sont des
administratifs des juristes ont pris un
certain nombre de considérants pour
pouvoir attribuer de manière légale
réglementaire d'une autorisation de port
d'armes la mission de police
elle fait référence à un arrêté qui leur
permet de me délivrer cette autorisation
alors est-ce que ce que j'ai mal terme
c'est bancal juridiquement ou pas je ne
sais pas moi même je suis pas un expert
des arrêtés de port d'armes
je dis simplement que la préfecture de
police
après enquête administrative savoir s'il
y avait bien bien-fondé quant à la
demande
deuxième chose cet arrêté intervient en
septembre en octobre de fin septembre ou
début octobre de mémoire et donc je suis
un interlocuteur connu de la préfecture
de police et par là quand ma présence en
vain pendant la campagne présidentielle
et pourra me présence sur les
déplacements du président de la
république
donc il ya sûrement eu un certain nombre
de démarches administratives internes à
la préfecture de police
sur la base de la requête de patrick
strzoda qui a aucun cas dit avec 110 des
policiers ou alexandre il s'occupe les
termes sont inexacts donc c'est un
certain nombre de considérants
rencontre le principal c'est à dire la
menace qui pouvait peser à un moment sur
moi et donc ils ont délivré un document
qui me permettait de justifier à
l'occasion desquelles je portais mon
arme et s'est précisée dans mes missions
et je tiens à répondre à la question
doit être posée après mes pauses dans
vos missions donc mes missions c'est
quoi c'est l'organisation des
déplacements etc
mais la mission quand vous êtes à
cabinet du président de la république
allait permanente
elle s'arrête pas là mission donc quand
vous quand je rentrais chez moi je
rentrais chez moi avec mon arbre
incluant cinq globes 43 sur moi jusqu'à
mon domicile
voilà donc ce n'est pas banal à vous
comprenez que comédie dont on a voulu
faire les choses en règle et la
préfecture de police
énoncer des motivations qui permettait
au port d'armes d'être légal tout à fait
est ce qu'on ne peut pas en déduire que
si vous n'aviez pas eu la mission de
police relevé par le préfet de police
mais si vous aviez fait la demande
uniquement en disant c'est pour ma
sécurité personnelle
normalement et légalement le permis de
port d'armes aurait dû vous être refusé
alors c'est pas tout à fait exact comme
il l'a été au ministère de l'intérieur à
deux reprises sur ce que je vais
repréciser encore il a été refusé à deux
reprises par le ministère de l'intérieur
sur des motifs administratifs sur des
problèmes non pas de deux opportunités
ou par même si à un moment sur le
premier port d'armes est intervenu une
décision de frédéric auréal chef du sdlp
qui n'a pas souhaité que je puisse
porter une arme pendant cette campagne
présidentielle sur le deuxième la
deuxième demande c'est un problème
purement administratif parce que je
n'avais pas renouvelé en l'état en
faisant état de mes nouvelles fonctions
la demande et on avait relancé la
première demande ce qui a été refusé par
la dlp agi messieurs sûr je souhaite
terminer 6e cheminant sur l'autorisation
de port d'armes la mission de police
n'est pas un préalable à la délivrance
de l'autorisation de port d'armes
il est prévu par les textes de code de
la sécurité intérieure en espèces que
peut se voir délivrer tout fonctionnaire
exposés à des risques dans le cadre de
ses fonctions
une autorisation de port d'armes par le
préfet territorialement compétent en
l'espèce c'est le cas on a considéré la
préfecture de police à considérer que
mes fonctions étaient exposés et m'a
délivré une autorisation de port d'armes
sur la base du code de la sécurité
intérieure et gtc donc quand je dis
fonctionnaires ces fonctionnaires ou
agents publics
j'étais agent public finalement je vois
que vous ne connaissez pas si mal les
règles d'attribution des ports d'armes
alors monsieur le président en sueur
merci monsieur le président encore
beaucoup de questions
il nous a été refusé d'avoir accès aux
documents suivants la demande faite non
pas par vous même
mais comme vous l'avez dit dans un
second temps par monsieur le directeur
de cabinet de bord d'armes
il est étrange qu'on nous ait refusé de
la connaissance de ce document est ce
que vous avez ce document alors je pense
qu'il n'existe pas de documents vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que le directeur
de cabinet du président la république
est en lien avec tous les préfets il a
dû décrocher son téléphone et demande à
michel delpech de voir si dans les
règles il était possible de m'attribuer
une autorisation
je me considérais que ce port d'armes
qui a été refusé deux fois pour des
raisons administratives par le ministère
de l'intérieur a été attribué par
monsieur yann drouet que nous allons
recevoir sur un coup de téléphone
la lampe à une demande écrite alors je
pense que c'est pas la procédure en
l'espèce c'est que dans un premier temps
il ya une personne qui appelle une autre
personne et qui demande
voilà quelle situation on est confronté
ce que vous pouvez regarder si c'est
possible si ça rentre dans les clous des
ans patrick strzoda quelqu'un d'assez
prudent et de trait dans les règles et
c'est quelqu'un de très droit c'est
quelqu'un de très droit il n'exerçait
aucune pression ni téléphonique n'est
simplement il a appelé préfet de police
en lui disant voilà la situation dans
laquelle est avec sans nom qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire et le préfet de police
par la suite a saisi ses services son
cabinet dans un premier temps donc son
chef de cabinet ian drew et et yann
drouet a saisi la direction de la police
générale qui a écrit cet arrêté et donc
par là avant d'écrire cet art était
d'ailleurs qui m'a demandé un certain
nombre de documents justificatifs
permettant de prouver un et d'ailleurs
ils sont mentionnés il me semble dans
l'arrêté que j'avais les capacités à
porter une arme
que je n'étais pas soumis à quelconque
problème d'ordre psychologique mais
dites donc j'ai fourni un certain nombre
de documents
mais les échanges des cris se font entre
l'intéressé et les services pas entre le
préfet de police
et ils sont directs et le directeur de
cabinet du président la république il
s'appelle il va plaider enfin je pense
qu'il n'a pas le temps déjà de pouvoir
écrire un courrier il ya une saisie
administrative officiel entre
l'intéressé et le service le service en
l'occurrence la direction la police
générale son quatrième bureau de mémoire
pourquoi aviez-vous jugé utile d'obtenir
la possibilité d'accéder à tout lieu au
sein de l'assemblée nationale j'ai bien
vu que vous n'aviez pas sollicité cela
pour le sénat dès l'acte mais pourquoi
était-il nécessaire que vous puissiez le
accéder y compris à l'hémicycle alors
badens à l'intérieur mais juste à
l'entrée
je dispose alors ça peut paraître
complètement irréaliste mais sur la
liste de ce que j'ai pu dire mais c'est
la réalité depuis que j'ai travaillé au
parti socialiste
j'ai été bénévoles et salariés au parti
société fait les deux j'ai bénéficié
d'un badge d'accès dans ce qu'on appelle
les collaborateurs occasionnels
collaborateurs bénévoles
je citerai pas les noms des deux députés
qu'il nous avait accordée mais quand
vous avez ce type de badges vous avez
accès à la bibliothèque
c'est là où j'ai préparé mes examens de
master et vous avez accès à la salle de
sport que j'ai continuer d'emprunter
quand vous êtes collaborateur du
président la république et vous
sollicitez ce un badge de manière
automatique les services administratifs
de l'assemblée nationale vous délivre un
match collaborateurs d'emmanuel macron
il est écrit dessus avec un h pour parce
que c'est le plus haut
niveau d'accès mais ce n'est pas une
demande qui analyse et c'est notre
process automatique c'est à dire que
vous avez le conseiller politique ou le
secrétariat du conseil politique qui
fait la demande de badge
je les dis je reconnais c'est un caprice
personnel c'est pourquoi je continue à
la salle de sports la bibliothèque
voilà bon mais il n'y avait pas de
demande particulière avoir accès à toute
l'assemblée
d'ailleurs je sais pas ce que j'aurais
fait dans l'hémicycle ma tête est
inconnu par un certain nombre de
parlementaires jeu mais si vous avez
bien conscience sociale et nahla que
l'attribution de ce type de carte n'est
pas destiné à permettre aux
bénéficiaires d'aller faire du sport
l'exclusion de toute nécessité de
service dans les relations avec les
parlementaires
alors pour être très précis où je des
associations au sein de l'assemblée
nationale auquel je payais ma cotisation
et qui sont ouvertes à n'importe quel
citoyen et qui sont animés non pas par
des administratifs de l'assemblée
nationale mais par des gens extérieurs
mais un certain nombre de clubs de sport
il ya le club de rugby par exemple de
l'assemblée nationale et à club de golf
de l'assemblée nationale et qui est
ouvert à un certain nombre de personnes
qui soient des collaborateurs ou pas au
même titre que la présidence de la
république et son association sportive
est ouvert aux extérieurs
donc je n'y allais pas pour y accéder a
qu'à voir un accès privilégié à
l'assemblée nationale mais parce que au
même titre qu'au sénat vous avez aussi
une association sportive et culturelle
qui est ouverte à des gens extérieurs au
sénat que ce soit vos familles où que ce
soit des gens extérieurs tout simplement
tout à l'heure vous avez confirmé que la
sanction vous l'apercevez comme une
rétrogradation vous ai même dit une
humiliation après qu'on vous ait informé
que vous ne cordeau ne riez plus les
voyages du président vous n'aviez donc
plus aucune mission et le chef de
cabinet nous a dit vous avez des
missions de synchronisation de cortège
pour l'essentiel après sanctions vous
avez continué à conduire une voiture qui
était badgés police a continué à porter
une arme
c'est ma première question la seconde
c'est la suite de ce cas vous a dit
monsieur canard on a été quelques uns
ici est membre du gouvernement
l'épaule droite et l'épaule gauche
d'amis nice d'un président d'un premier
ministre c'est toujours les de
l'officier de sécurité et dans les
photos on vous voit comme étant dans ce
rôle physiquement je pars là
dans les photos e
même quand le président ou un ministre
est approché par quelqu'un souvent
l'officier de sécurité sert d'interface
pour apporter les dossiers ou telle ou
telle question
donc ma question et c est moi qui ai
fréquenté beaucoup l'elysée matignon
ça a toujours été comme ça c'est donc un
changement de pratique comment vous
l'expliquez de la fonction d'un officier
de sécurité s'est pas de porter les
dossiers le manteau ou de passer des
messages à la personne qui le protège
c'est de le protéger c'est d'être
attentif c'est de regarder ce qui se
passe autour de lui la question ont
fonctionné dire je crois je parle sous
le contrôle de monsieur daubresse
si vous vous êtes dans une position
caractéristiques de la protection à
l'épaule ou et le garde du corps qui
fait la protection à l'épaule je pense
que vous avez vu tous ces images il
était soit à droite si j'étais à gauche
soit gauche si j'étais à droite c'est
visible sur les images il n'ya pas il
n'ya pas de place prédéfinis et je
voulais expliquer tout à l'heure
simplement c'est que il faut un moment
comprendre que les officiers de sécurité
se sont pas les vallées des personnes
qui protège et donc ils sont dans des
fonctions de sécurité ils se sont
adaptés et je leur explique pas ce que
je pense pas avoir été clair tout à
l'heure je suis désolé c'est que ça
donnait ça a donné lieu à des
discussions entre le chef du j'espère et
le chef de cabinet sur la proximité
physique y compris du chef de cabinet
lors des déplacements du président de la
république monsieur benalla vos
compétences en matière de sécurité sont
incontestables ce qui paraît moins
vraisemblable c'est qu'on nous dise que
vous occupiez de tout sauf de sécurité
lors on en a parlé il ya vos attitudes
est chef professionnel c'était des
survivants se les mentions de l'arrêté
du préfet de police octroyant le port
dame qui fait expressément référence à
ça les déclarations des syndicats nous
parlant de comportement autoritaire et
déplacer ou de relations exécrables que
j'espère alors vous contestez ses propos
mais vous avez quand même reconnu que
vous étiez considéré par un extra
terrestre je comprends votre expression
ou comme ingénieur en termes plus crus
alors n'était ce pas parce que justement
vous ingérer dans leur champ de
compétence sur le port d'armes
vous n'avez pas été aussi clair même
qu'on nous l'a dit il
ce qui n'était jamais dans les
déplacements publics seulement dans les
déplacements privés alors deux questions
précises sur les déplacements privés où
vous étiez armée était ce parce que le
j'espère était absent vous avez expliqué
même le président vous n'avez positif
léger où était son double assurance et
dans les déplacements publics donniez
vous d instruction ou des ordres aux
policiers et gendarmes gradés ou non
quand je dis qu'on me qualifie
d'extraterrestres jeu faisait pas
référence aux officiers de sécurité du
j'espère je faisais référence à un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
dans l'administration sont démonstratif
pur jus pour lequel j'ai pas tout à fait
le profil de l'emploi
quand j'explique qu'il pouvait y avoir
des tensions avec eux c'est parce que je
suis un peu dans l'esprit du président
c'est que quand on me demande de faire
quelque chose je le fais je vais un peu
jusqu'au bout et parfois vous attirer
des inimités de gens qui vous explique
que ça fait 40 ans qu'on fait comme ça
et qu'on vous a pas attendu pour changer
les choses
bah ça peut créer des tensions parfois
et quand vous faites pas partie du club
excusez moi de l'expression et bien on
vous le reproche on vous le fait sentir
en tout cas d'une manière différente
c'était là dessus que il y avait cette
affaire de j'avais d'être qualifiés ont
qualifié d' extraterrestes pardon sur
les déplacements privés le port d'armes
il ya toujours eu toujours eu est le
seul responsable de la sécurité du
président de la république c'est le
général lavernhe il ya toujours eu des
éléments du j'espère en permanence avec
le président de la république il s'est
jamais retrouvé seul ni avec un dossier
de sécurité ni avec moi il ya toujours
eu un dispositif complet jamais je n'ai
jamais eu de trou dans la raquette de la
sécurité du président de la république a
toujours eu le dispositif même parfois
quand il était minimum mais il ya
toujours eu de la sécurité autour du
président de la république officiel
toujours eu les forces de police ou de
gendarmerie avec lui est-ce que je
portais mon arme comme une assurance
d'assurance pour moi même je reste
président la république je rentre pas
chez lui
je rentre chez moi après quand j'ai fini
donc je la portais pour moi même pour ma
sécurité personnelle encore une fois je
le répète
monsieur benalla à vous écouter nous
avons le sentiment qu'il est très
difficile de ne pas franchir la ligne de
crête est étroite entre les fonctions de
coordination d'organisations d'un côté
et les fonctions de policier de sécurité
de l'autre vous dites ne pas avoir
exercé des missions de police et de
sécurité
mais nous avons des témoignages de
journalistes dans deux circonstances qui
atteste que vous auriez et des images
parfois que vous auriez procédé à des
fouilles et un contrôle d'identité
c'est à la mongie en décembre 2017 et à
marseille à une notification de mise en
garde à vue d'un photographe fait ce que
vous pouvez nous répondre sur cette
question je n'ai jamais fouillé ou
contrôler l'identité d'un journaliste
quand vous êtes je vais vous prendre un
exemple assez des scripts de comprendre
vous allez mieux comprendre la fonction
quand on était en guyane il ya des gens
qui ont attaqué la préfecture je réponds
à la question madame d'un contre et s'il
vous plaît juste je réponds à la
question vous avez l'autorité
administrative le secrétaire général la
préfecture en l'occurrence qui est à
côté de vous et vous avez 500 personnes
qui attaquent des gendarmes qui
attaquent les policiers qui attaquent la
préfecture il se tourne vers vous et ils
vous demandent qu'est-ce qu'on fait
je sais que ce que je dis est pas
politiquement correct mais c'est la
réalité
l'autorité administrative ne prendra
aucune décision sans l'aval de
l'autorité politique et donc vous
représentez le cabinet du président de
la république donc si à un moment où
vous demande est ce que je dois prendre
tels moyens ou si vous devez orienter la
manière dont vous voyez les choses
eh ben vous le faites et quand vous avez
des gens qui atteignent à la vie privée
du président de la république qui le
harcèle sur son lieu de vacances
vous prenez en responsabilité des
décisions qui sont celles de dire aux
policiers du j'espère qu'ils ne savent
pas s'ils doivent le faire ou pas le
faire quand la personne a franchi les
limites est rentré sur une propriété
privée pour photographier madame ou
monsieur en maillot de bain eh bien vous
expliquer aux policiers il n'a pas le
faire mais quand on fait du
politiquement correct on dit non mais
j'ai pas donné l'ordre d'aller
interpeller
il a commis un délit il a été contrôlé
par les policiers il a été placé en
garde à vue par un commissaire de police
sa part alexandre ménard c'est bizarre
on va s'en tenir là pour cette réponse
j'attire l'attention des collègues que
si monsieur paix d'allah avait procédé
lui-même à des contrôles d'identité ou à
des fouilles se serait défait
potentiellement délictueux tout à fait
qu'il n'appartient pas à notre
commission dans lequel parlementaire de
l'amener à s'exprimer sur des délits
qu'ils auraient éventuellement commis ce
qui n'est pas le cas non plus loin et
dans
cette recherche de précisions vous avez
fait une réponse générale les dons
tiendront donc cette cette réponse
générale première mission qui était
celle de monsieur alexandre benalla
c'était de m'appuyer dans l'organisation
des déplacements nationaux
je voulais dire donc là je veux vivre à
nouveau une parenthèse m'appuyer ça veut
dire la possibilité pour lui de faire
des missions préparatoires
il en a fait très peu je les ai
quasiment tout fait de niveau national
personnellement eu égard à l'enjeu d'un
déplacement du président de la
république mais il en a fait par
ailleurs il est dans la pratique que
j'ai instauré avec mes équipes de faire
en sorte qu'un de mes oies des adjoints
soient présents quelques heures avant
l'arrivée du président de la république
sur un déplacement et donc mais
d'arriver à de très nombreuses reprises
conduit très nombreuses reprises
on a dû organiser qu'elle une centaine
de déplacements du président de la
république en un an et trois mois en
national à l'international
donc de l'envoyer en avance de phase
pour vérifier que le dispositif mis en
place était stabilisé et donc il a fait
ses missions dites entre guillemets de
précurseur je suis désolé c'est d'un
affreux jargon auprès de ma première
mission l'organisation de déplacements
nationaux
je veux fortement vous dire sur ce point
là que monsieur benalla était très
précis dans l'organisation de dans ses
fonctions et que vous savez l'importance
qu'accordent les préfets dans
l'organisation des déplacements du
président de la république et que jamais
je n'ai entendu un préfet de la
république se plaindre de ce qu'a pu
faire monsieur benalla dans ses missions
préparatoires ou de précurseur vous en
avez d'ailleurs je crois entendus d'eux
fera pas qu'ils aient qu'ils aient pu
dire quoi que ce soit sur le vélo je
vous avais deuxième d'autres
circonstances cantons sur cette centaine
de voyages vous avez entendu des préfet
se plaindre au chef de cabinet du
président de la république du
comportement de notre collaborateur du
tout deuxièmement peut-être que j'ai
oublié une négation mais donc je répète
jamais aucun préfet de la république ne
s'est plaint de monsieur benalla dans
l'organisation de ses déplacements
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure parce que
vous m'interrogerais certainement sur
l'existence d'autres plaintes il n'y en
a pas eu
deuxièmement deuxièmement deuxièmement
comme les autres chargés de mission de
l'elysée l'organisation des événements
au palais de l'elysée ça va du
rendez-vous à la réception
mobilisant plus de 1200 invités hier des
très gros événement organisé au palais
de l'elysée troisièmement la
coordination des deux services la
coordination et c'est comme ça que nous
l'avons voulue sous l'autorité du
directeur de cabinet et donc pas la
mienne la coordination des deux services
de sécurité de l'elysée
le j'espèrais le commandement militaire
en quoi consistait cette coordination
lorsque vous allez me poser la question
très simplement nous avons vu en
arrivant au palais de l'elysée que deux
services de sécurité se côtoyaient que
sur des sujets très qui n'ont rien à
voir d'ailleurs avec l'exercice de
prérogatives de sécurité il y avait une
meilleure coexistence a organisé entre
notamment sur les questions
je suis désolé ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
sans doute parce que vous attendez mais
en tous les cas sur des choses très
prosaïque tels que le parc automobile
savoir comment faire en sorte par
exemple pour que le parc automobile du
jeu espère soit rénové et réhaussée
organiser la coexistence de ces deux
services par rapport aux résidences du
président de la république donc des
choses très très administrative est
absolument pas en lien avec une
immixtion de quelque nature que ce soit
dans le commandement des deux chefs de
service que ce soit le chef du jeu
espère où le général commandant
militaire du palais
voilà quel était qu'elles sont quels
étaient les missions d'alexandre ben
alors j'y ajoute également mais nous le
faisions tous également là la
préparation de déplacement non
officielle du président dans le public
mais alors ça c'est quelque chose qui
fait je crois beaucoup parlé mais le
président de la république
même lorsque son déplacement n'est pas
médiatisé qu'ils se déplacent ça se
prépare ça se prépare ça se prépare en
termes d'organisation en terme d'accueil
je veux pas rentrer dans des détails
parce que je crois que je sortirai de
mon rôle et du mandat qui m'a été donnée
mais un président par exemple ça ne se
déplace pas seul donc il faut organiser
l'alimentation de personnes qui se
déplacent avec lui
quand il se déplace il faut prévenir les
personnes à l'endroit où ils se
déplacent c'est ça le rôle du chargé de
mission du chef de cabinet dans la
réalisation des déplacements non
publique du président de la république
donc il avait également ce rôle l'arrêt
puis nono répartition en fonction d'un
tour que je décide et de ses missions
voilà donc ses fonctions
elles ont été extrêmement clair depuis
le début cadrée est arrêté par mes soins
sous l'autorité du directeur de cabinet
lorsque j'ai
commencé ma carrière de sous préfet mon
premier préfet m'a dit françois xavier
lorsque vous êtes directeur de cabinet
que vous avez la responsabilité par
délégation d'un dispositif d'ordre
public
ne prenez pas la place des policiers des
gendarmes
votre relation avec le directeur de la
police avec le colonel de gendarmerie
c'est de lui donner des effets obtenir à
dire voilà ce qu'il ne doit pas arriver
et de le laisser faire son oeuvre
le rôle d'un chef de cabinet dans une
mission préparatoire et lors d'un
déplacement c'est exactement la même
chose donc par délégation du chef de
cabinet alexandre bédat la chargée de
mission a pu demander des effets obtenir
sur un déplacement que ce soit au préfet
de police que ça soit un préfet de
département que ça soit un chef du
j'espère mais il n'a jamais pris la
place du policier ou du gendarme et en
ce sens il n'a pas exercé de missions de
police et je puis vous dire que si
j'avais constaté cela il se serait fait
là aussi fermement sermonne ce chef de
cabinet je vais redonner la parole à
jean pierre sueur mais voyez je vous
demande pas de vous mettre notre place
mais il ya des éléments contradictoires
et j'entends bien ce que vous dites et
il entend aussi votre sincérité mais le
préfet de police quand il délivre un
permis de port d'armes
il le fait bien sur la base des
informations qui lui ont été données par
l'elysée et qu'est ce qu'il écrit il
elle relève un certain nombre de
considérants parmi lesquels je lis ceci
considérant que monsieur benalla est
chargé d'une mission de police dans le
cadre de son action de coordination de
la sécurité de la présidence de la
république avec les forces militaires et
le gspr donc peut-être que nous
entendons mal sur les mots mais en tous
les cas il a bien fallu que l'élysée dix
autres fêtes police il a une mission de
police sinon il n'aurait pas eu du port
d'armes
mais également on peut se dire pourquoi
a t'on demandé à trois
reprise avant d'obtenir un permis de
port d'armes pour monsieur benalla s'il
n'a strictement aucune fonction de
sécurité
et je rappelle d'ailleurs que le métier
de monsieur bénalia avant d'entrer d'un
président de la république est
exclusivement un métier de sécurité
c'est sa spécialité c'est ce qu'il a
appris et c'est son expérience
professionnelle et mettez vous à la
place de nos concitoyens comme de
nous-mêmes nous ne nions une commission
d' enquête pour savoir les choses
clairement et il est mais pour nous
difficile de comprendre la réalité des
choses quand nous sommes en présence de
contradictions et j'ai bien entendu ce
que vous avez dit est ce que vous avez
dit répond à une logique d'organisation
qui est tout à fait souhaitable mais
voyez c'est c'est eh voyez nous avons
des éléments qui sont sur notre table
monsieur nov non je maintiens évidemment
mais mes propos je ne suis pas le
rédacteur de
ce texte réglementaire pris par le
préfet de police vous l'avez interrogé
peut-être renters il faut peut-être le
réinterroger mais sur ce premier point
excusez moi mais qui a demandé le permis
pour lire jeu je crois que patrick
strzoda a été très très clairs là dessus
c'est lui qui a été en contact avec la
préfecture de police sur ce sujet là
pour quoi faire
c'est lui qui a été en contact avec la
préfecture de police sur ce sujet là il
a demandé et je vous prie de de
reprendre les propos qu'il a tenus
devant cette commission
il a demandé à la préfecture de police
d'analyser cette demande dans les règles
de droit non mon pour mon cas personnel
mon cas personnel cette demande cette
demande de port d'armes dans le cas
d'espèce fondée sur des questions de
sécurité donc à différencier d'une d'une
protection personnelle n'a pas transité
par mes mains donc essais et je m'en
explique et c'est normal puisque les
questions de sécurité sont traitées
directement sous l'autorité du directeur
de cabinet donc je ne peux pas vous
répondre plus avant moi je ne sais ce
que je peux vous contenter de vous dire
et là aussi en restant à la place qui
est la mienne qui est celle de chef de
cabinet c'est l'émission que j'ai
conférer à monsieur benalla et je
voulais expliquer je prends en détail
faîtière forme et qu'il bénéficiait d'un
port d'armes
oui j'en ai été informé et vous donnons
mandat de prendre son arme pour
certaines missions et là aussi je vais
être très clair comme je crois vous le
dit le général lavernhe je n'ai jamais
vu monsieur bien là avec son arme sur
une mission du président de la
république est en tous les cas pour les
missions qui sont des missions
officielles je ne l'aurais pas accepté
puisque la sécurité du président de la
république est assurée par ailleurs par
le j'espère et par les forces de police
et de gendarmerie mobilisées sur
l'autorité des préfets pourquoi monsieur
benalla avait-il un véhicule de service
un peu étonné ça peut peut-être choquer
parce que monsieur benalla il passait
ses journées et le début de ses nuits au
palais comme on le fait tous pour
organiser les déplacements du président
de la république
il n'était donc pas étonnant qu'on
puisse lui confier un véhicule pour se
rendre sur les lieux de ses missions et
le soir pour rentrer chez lui le matin
pour en revenir c'est précisément la
définition d'un véhicule de service
deuxièmement sur les moyens lumineux et
sur les avertisseurs sonores dont
étaient dotés le véhicule il se trouve
que l'ensemble du parc de véhicules de
l'elysée est doté de ses moyens lumineux
et sonore pour la simple et bonne raison
que ces véhicules peuvent être intégrés
dans des cortèges et vous savez que
quand le président de la république
circule encore tagil et fait usage de
ses moyens lumineux généralement pas
sonore d'ailleurs pour des raisons de
protection du président de la république
de bonne circulation du cortège de
sécurité des autres automobilistes donc
dire qu'il y a sur ce véhicule des
moyens est une chose c'est pas forcément
pour cela qu'ils sont utilisés et s'ils
le sont ils doivent l'être dans des
règles de sécurité que que vous
connaissez donc oui à l'elysée il ya des
véhicules avec ce type de moyens il me
semble que c'est légal c'est pas la
seule institution à disposer de
véhicules avec ce type de moyens je me
contenterai de quelques mots
introductifs très bref tout d'abord je
tiens à
commencez par souscrire pleinement
réponse qui vous ont été apportées hier
par le directeur de cabinet du président
de la république patrick strzoda qui
comme vous le savez tous et un préfet de
très grande expérience dont le sens de
l'état et reconnu par tous et qui a
toute ma confiance
j'ajoute que je considère que c'est une
grande chance pour moi comme secrétaire
général de la présidence de la
république de de pouvoir compter sur son
concours quotidien
[Musique]
comme vous l'a également indiqué patrick
strzoda le président de la république a
autorisé certaines ses collaborateurs à
venir devant vous afin de contribuer à
la manifestation de la vérité
il m'a néanmoins demandé de rappeler le
cadre juridique dans lequel s'inscrit
cette audition il me semble en
particulier déterminant de souligner
vous avez fait vous même monsieur
président l'importance du respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés qui me permettra
pas de répondre aux questions portant
sur les faits donnant lieu à des
poursuites judiciaires ou à celle
portant sur l'organisation interne de la
présidence de la république
j'en viens à présent à l'objet même de
votre commission et aux événements du
1er mai j'ai passé l'après-midi du 1er
mai dernier à mon bureau le directeur de
cabinet m'a tenu informé du déroulement
des manifestations et des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
je rappelle que ces manifestations se
sont révélés d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle au regard des violences
commises des commerces saccagés des
dégradations constatées et d un perte
interpellations auxquelles les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé
je veux saisir cette occasion pour
saluer l'engagement sans faille des
forces de l'ordre et le
professionnalisme dont elles ont fait
preuve au cours de ces événements la
question des événements de la place de
la contrescarpe now n'a à aucun moment
été mentionné j'ai été informé le
lendemain le 2 mai dans la matinée par
le conseiller en charge notamment des
réseaux sociaux et le directeur de
cabinet de la publication sous les
réseaux sociaux d'une vidéo dans
laquelle un individu
keith a par s apparenter à monsieur
bénard se livrer à des actes
inappropriés et choquants dans le cadre
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre
sur la place de la contrescarpe à ce
moment nous dire et autres cabinets
m'indique qu'il a d'ores et déjà
convoqué l'intéressé qui a reconnu sa
présence sur les lieux et sa
participation des interpellations
je m'assure que le directeur de cabinet
a bien vérifié auprès de la préfecture
de police et du cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur de la réalité des faits est
retracée dans la vidéo et qu'ils sont
bien informés
nous refaisons le point en fin de
journée
constatant que les faits sont bien
avérée le directeur de cabinet m'informe
de son intention d'appliquer une
sanction disciplinaire sans délai ce qui
me semble totalement approprié nous nous
reparlons le lendemain et le directeur
de cabinet ma forme de la sanction
qu'ils entendent notifié à l'agent et
donc il vous a parlé hier la suspension
de quinze jours avec votre salaire la
modification des responsabilités
confiées à l'intéressé la notification
portée au dossier
l'indication que tout nouveau
comportement fautif entraînerait un
licenciement qu'ils aient lieu par la
suite
compte tenu des éléments portés à notre
connaissance à ce moment là la sanction
apparaît proportionnée au bout du compte
la sanction a été décidée dès le jour de
la découverte des chais et notifiée à
l'intéressé
dès le lendemain j'ajoute un point
compte tenu de l'audition du directeur
de cabinet patrick strzoda hier devant
vous et devant les députés de celle du
commandant militaire du palais de
l'elysée j'ai un bio farina et du chef
du gspr le club venait de lavergne je
pense j'espère que vous avez été rassuré
sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas à
l'elysée de police parallèle que nous
n'employons pas de vigiles privés pour
protéger le chef de l'état et que
monsieur benalla n'a jamais été en
charge de la protection du président
république je vous remercie et sur votre
disposition pour répondre à l'ensemble
de vos questions merci monsieur le
secrétaire général de ce tour
préliminaire
il ya un point que vous n'avez pas
spontanément abordés mais qui me paraît
utile de préciser pour que l'ensemble de
mes collègues comprennent votre rôle
auprès du chef de l'état nous exercer
une fonction dont j'entends dire qu'elle
est très importante mais c'est une
fonction qui n'est pas public d'une
certaine façon car mise à part une
exception jamais le secrétaire général
de la présidence de la république ne
s'exprime publiquement sauf pour lire
sur le perron de l'élysée la liste des
membres du gouvernement ce qui lui
assure une grande notoriété mais elle
n'est que temporaire mes collègues et
nos concitoyens qu'ils suivent nos
travaux sont certainement impatients que
vous puissiez pour éclairer le contexte
7 et 10 positions expliqué ce que vous
faites
monsieur le président je vous remercie
une certaine manière nous permet
d'accéder à une certaine notoriété
cette occasion au delà de notoriété
furtif que m'a donné la possibilité
d'énumérer la liste des membres du
gouvernement sur le perron de l'elysée
et vous avez raison de rappeler que
j'aurais probablement dû commencer par
rappeler en quoi consiste mais les
fonctions qui sont les miennes
comme ce qu intervient la présence de la
république
comme vous le savez vous même si vous
allez occuper ce poste
le secrétaire-général et n'est pas pour
moi que je posais la question je viens
d'entendre je suis bien longtemps le
secrétaire général est le collaborateur
direct du président de la république
probablement son principal collaborateur
et pilote l'action de la présidence et
des équipes de la présidence en
particulier en ce qui concerne les
politiques publiques et évidemment
chacun dans son rôle en lien avec le
premier ministre et le gouvernement pour
ce faire le secrétaire général s'appuie
sur différentes organisations et aux
partis du cabinet ou des services de la
présidence
en particulier l'état major particulier
du président de la république pour ce
qui concerne les questions de défense
le pôle diplomatique pour ce qui
concerne la question des questions
touchant aux affaires étrangères le pôle
e régalien vous sur les questions
intérieures ou territoriales et les
équipes du du cabinet qui sont chargés
de conseiller le président de la
république dans les différents domaines
de l'action publique que je n'ai ni mère
aurait pas par ailleurs au-delà du du
cabinet du président la république
la présidence est une assez grande
maison vous pourrez trouver tous les
détails dans le rapport de là
cour des comptes sur sa gestion pour
l'année 2010 est eux qui étaient publiés
se faire de ma part avant-hier avec le
premier président est venu présenter au
président républicain entière et vous
verrez que les services de la présidence
de la public compte un peu plus de 800
personnes en ce compris des services
dont je pense qu'on aura l'occasion de
dirhams en aujourd'hui comme le
commandement militaire du palais qui
assurent l'intégrité la sécurité des
bâtiments
l'entretien le gspr pour la sécurité du
présent à la république
une grande quantité de services supports
qui permettent de faire fonctionner
cette cette maison enfin pour ce qui
concerne la gestion interne de la
présidence de la république en
particulier la gestion de son personnel
la gestion de son de son budget et d'une
façon générale toute question qui touche
vraiment à l'organisation y compris sur
les questions de sécurité le secrétaire
général s'appuie sur le directeur de
cabinet que vous avez auditionné hier au
cas d'espèce patrick strzoda et qui me
rend compte c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle je ne vous ferai pas de
réponse aussi détaillé que celle que
patrick strzoda a pu vous faire hier
ou aussi technique puisque il est
véritablement en charge de la gestion
interne à la maison encore une fois on
me rendant compte et de manière
quotidienne
voilà j'espère avoir répondu à la
question de votre question au nom de vos
collègues je vous remercie monsieur le
secrétaire général sur le secrétaire
général le 2 mai dernier une sanction
est donc prise à l'encontre de monsieur
benalla mais ce jour là la sanction se
limite à une mise à pied de quinze jours
sortie des différents éléments que vous
avez rappelé à l'instant dont un
prélèvement sur le salaire dont nous
avons appris hier qu'il n'avait pas
encore eu lieu mais ce jour là il n'est
pas mis fin aux fonctions de monsieur
benalla et ni à la présidence de la
république ni au gouvernement ni à la
préfecture de police
on ne signale les faits au parquet je
voulais vous demander si
rétrospectivement
vous avez conscience des risques que
pouvaient faire courir au chef de l'état
le maintien dans l'effectif de la
présidence de la république d'un
individu qui avait révélé de tels
comportements est-ce que vous avez pris
conscience de la gravité du trouble
apporter au fonctionnement de l'état par
l'abus de la qualité de collaborateur du
chef de l'état dans l'intrusion qui
s'était produite dans la hiérarchie de
la police à l'occasion d'une opération
de maintien de l'ordre
est ce que vous avez à ce moment là où
maintenant pris conscience de la
nécessité de réexaminer l'articulation
entre les collaborateurs du président de
la république et les services du
gouvernement pour que la séparation des
pouvoirs entre présidence de la
république et gouvernement
soit désormais mieux assurée il ne fait
aucun doute et je dois dire que dans
cette question il n'y a eu aucun doute
il n'y a eu aucun débat au sein de la
présidence de la république
lorsque les faits ont été connus sur le
fait que c'est fait costil était non
seulement inappropriée choquant comme je
les dis mais également constituer une
faute
j'insiste sur ce point mais aucun
malentendu je n'ai véritablement eu
aucune discussion sur ce sujet il était
de l'ordre de l'évidence pour tout le
monde que le comportement de monsieur
benalla devait être sanctionné j'ajoute
sur plus qu' il était évident pour tout
le monde que cette sanction devait
intervenir rapidement et c'est la raison
pour laquelle l'enchaînement des faits
est assez rapide puisque immédiatement
après le jour même de la connaissance
des faits la décision est prise et elle
lui est notifié le lendemain cette
sanction doit être semble-t-il apprécié
à la lumière des faits et des éléments
dont nous disposions à l'époque nous
disposions à l'époque en tout cas à mon
niveau et compte tenu des discussions
que j'ai pu avoir avec le directeur de
cabinet de la vidéo qui avaient circulé
sur les sur les réseaux sociaux du
contexte de violence particulier des
manifestations du 1er mai et des
informations qui ont pu nous être
communiquées par le ministère de
l'intérieur la préfecture de police et
m'être communiqués par l'intermédiaire
de médiateurs de cabinet
la vidéo montre d'abord la participation
de monsieur benalla à cette
manifestation équipé d'un casque
évidemment
ne manque pas de citer pour le moins des
questions et le journal il m'a été
confirmé que la préfecture de police
accueillait de nombreux observateurs et
que pour les accueillir elle leur
fournissait leurs équipements je note
que c'est un point qui m'a été dit
d'emblée mais qui par la suite a été a
été confirmée avec elle en particulier
confirmé par le préfet de police
lorsqu'il a été auditionné devant
l'assemblée nationale a aussi été
confirmée de manière plus détaillée par
le commandant militaire du palais
monsieur bio farina lorsqu il relaté une
conversation à laquelle il assistait en
tout état de cause il a des profits liés
aux polices accueille régulièrement des
observateurs et les équipes de ce point
de vue là l'équipement d'un cas ce que
semblait correspondre à la pratique
habituelle mais j'ai vu de couleur dans
la presse
des photographies d'autres observateurs
plus lourdement équipements deuxièmement
la vidéo montre que monsieur benalla a
participé à l'interpellation de
manifestants là aussi on en droit de
s'interroger
il m'a été indiqué que cette
interpellation
certes musclées ne montrait pas de coups
violents n'infliger pas de blessure et
cette analyse à me semble-t-il été
confirmée hier ou avant-hier par la
directrice le l'igpn qui a décrit
c'est ces circonstances il m'a par
ailleurs été indiqué que les personnes
interpellées n'avait pas fait l'objet
dit été ou de dépôt de plainte
troisièmement la vidéo rend compte de
manière partielle depuis leur complété
par par d'autres vidéos du contexte
particulier les violences non seulement
ce jour là j'en ai parlé mais également
sur la place de la contrescarpe il m'a
été confirmé que c'était un niveau de
violence exceptionnelle et que les
personnes interpellées avaient
effectivement agresser les forces de
l'ordre c'est un point qu'il aussi été
confirmée par différentes vidéos
par la suite c'est un élément de
contexte important il m'a été dit par la
suite qu'il y avait eu trente et une
interpellation place de la contrescarpe
ce soir là sur 276 au cours de la
journée nous tels sont les éléments dont
nous disposions demande secrétaire d'une
je vous interromps juste vous remercie
d'être très précis dans les éléments
d'information dont vous nous on vous
nous fournissez moi ma question c'était
les deux mais monsieur benalla se voit
infliger une sanction mais il n'est pas
mis fin à ses fonctions
il n'est pas décidé de saisir la justice
est ce que vous aviez conscience le 2
mai ou es ce que vous avez pris
conscience depuis lors des risques que
faisait courir au président de la
république le maintien d'une telle
collaboration avec un agent qui s'était
ainsi comporter est ce que vous avez eu
conscience à ce moment là où pris
conscience depuis de la gravité du
trouble apporter au fonctionnement de
l'état à l'intrusion d'un collaborateur
du président de la république dans une
opération de maintien de l'ordre à
laquelle il a participé
et est ce que vous avez pris conscience
de ce fait de l'utilité qu'il y aurait à
réexaminer les modalités générales de la
collaboration entre les services
de la présidence de la république et les
administrations placée sous l'autorité
du gouvernement voilà ma question
encore une fois je ne me connais
absolument pas la gravité des faits ni
ce jour là ni aujourd'hui ce qui aurait
été particulièrement grave et ce qui
aurait porté atteinte la présence de la
république de façon particulièrement
aiguës graves
ce matin qu'il n'y aurait pas eu de
réaction et pas eu de sanctions et c'est
pour ça que on a encore une fois insisté
pour qu'une sanction qu'il soit rapide
et pour ce qui est de l'article 40
compte tenu des éléments dont je dispose
et je n'avais pas d'élément me
permettant de penser qu'une saisine au
titre de l'article 40 serait justifié
j'ajoute pour être plus explicite
vous avez cité un nombre d'autorités qui
ont été informés au niveau du
gouvernement ou ailleurs et qu'aucune
autorité qui a eu à connaître de ces
faits n'a à ma connaissance même suggéré
l'opportunité d'un article 40 et je
crois que le directeur de cabinet nous a
par ailleurs répondu en détail sur ce
point et sur l'analyse qu'il a lui-même
fait je conçois parfaitement qu
aujourd'hui à la lumière des fêtes a
connu depuis lors dont certains je le
rappelle ont conduit au licenciement de
monsieur benalla puisque dans le
courrier de notification de la sanction
il eût été dit qu'à la prochaine faute
ils seraient licenciés de manière à ce
que on est une réponse qui soit
proportionné graduée qui ne reste
certainement pas sans conséquences dès
lors que de nouveaux faits se produire
et ça a été le cas et donc je maintiens
que la lumière des faits connus depuis
la sanction peut apparaître insuffisante
mais que symétriquement au regard des
éléments connus
le 2 mai cette sanction était
proportionné et j'ajoute que j'ai
entendu hier éric morvan le dgpn qui a
indiqué hier devant les députés que
placé dans la même situation il aurait
probablement pris la même décision
c'est votre réponse monsieur le
secrétaire général alors je voulais vous
poser une deuxième question je vous
l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure
c'est le point de vue que vous défendez
monsieur benalla n'exerçait pas de
fonction de protection personnelle
le directeur du cabinet du président de
la république nous a expliqué hier les
trois missions qui sont dans sa
définition de fonction laquelle a fait
l'objet d'une note que nous avons
demandé dans ces trois fonctions il y a
le déplacement privé du chef de l'état
nous avons fait l'hypothèse que ces
déplacements privés donné lieu à la mise
en oeuvre d'une forme de sécurité
adaptées à leur nature
c'est d'ailleurs une hypothèse qui nous
a été confirmée mais que monsieur
benalla à ce moment là doté d'un port
d'ars pouvait accompagner le président
de la république et assurer sa
protection
les il nous a été dit que ça n'était pas
le cas et du coup de nous sommes
interrogés sur l'utilité du port d'armes
qui lui a été attribué par ce qui nous a
aussi est indiqué que dans les
déplacements officiels du chef de l'état
il n'avait jamais son art le préfet de
police s'est inquiété de savoir si il
avait avec lui son arme pendant les
manifestations du 1er mai mais il
n'avait pas de réponse à cette
interrogation qu'il se faisait à lui
même
je voudrais savoir au nom de la
commission qu'elle était dans la mesure
où vous pouvez l'expliquer sans porter
préjudice à la sécurité du président de
la république
bien sûr mais quelle était la nature du
travail fait par monsieur ben alla pour
les déplacements privés du président de
la république
et si oui ou non il accompagnait le
président de la république avec une
dimension de protection personnelle
pendant ses déplacements privés
alors comme vous l'indiquez le travail
hier alexandre benalla était chargé de
mission auprès de la chefferie de
cabinet c'est à dire auprès de l'entité
qui au sein du cabinet prise en mains
publiques est chargée d'organiser son
agenda ses déplacements
et de s'assurer que tous les services
qui doivent concourir à l'exercice de sa
mission ou de ses déplacements que ce
soit en matière de sécurité de
communication de transport suit bien et
c'était bien la fonction d'élection de
benalla qui était donc à la chefferie et
tu n'étais pas en charge de la sécurité
il était donc en charge de l'interaction
entre la chefferie de cabinet qui doit
coordonner l'ensemble de ces éléments et
les personnes en charge de la sécurité
il y a deux types de service comme vous
le savez qui sont en charge de la
sécurité du président de la république
il est d'une part il ya d'une part un
peu fouillis caméra qui se fout il ya de
ne pas le commandement militaire du
palais il est en charge de l'intégralité
des bâtiments et de la sécurité du
président à l'intérieur des résidences
présidentielles
d'une part et qui est dirigé par le
général guillaud fine il y a pas donc le
général bio-farina eric bio vendangés de
secrétaire général je veux préciser le
poids du porn mauvaise par leurs
collègues
vous n'avez pas répondre aux
interpellations des collègues pendant le
cours de vos explications
je vous remercie et d'autre part
le groupement de sécurité présents dans
le public on me signale qu'on ne vous
entend pas toujours bien approché du
glay rapprocher du pardon de la
médiocrité de notre équipement
le d'autre part le j espere qui dirigé
par le colonel lavergne et qui
accompagne le président de la république
dans ses déplacements
la sécurité du président de la
république est toujours assurée en
toutes circonstances par l'une de ces
deux unités
c'est véritablement le commandement
militaire et le j'espère qu'ils sont en
charge et j'ajoute que ses services sont
exclusivement je deviens exclusivement
composée de personnels qui sont qui
relève soit de la police soit de la
gendarmerie
et ce sont eux qui sont responsables de
la sécurité
le président de la république je pense
que ce sont des points qui ont été ne
semble-t-il clarifié par les auditions
du général bio-farina du colonel
lavergne à l'assemblée nationale jeudi
je crois parce qu'elles ont eu lieu
pendant le conseil des ministres auquel
j'assiste et donc je n'ai pas pu les
voir du moins en direct et pour que ce
soit bien clair s'agissant de
l'interaction entre alexandre benalla et
ses services exemple elana n'appartenait
n'appartient ni au commandement
militaire ni aux jsp
il n'avait pas de responsabilité
les concernant ils n'étaient pas
pressenti pour occuper un poste de
responsabilité concernant services comme
j'ai pu le lire ici ou là c'est le
secrétaire général qui ne s'explique pas
si messieurs benalla n'avait pas une
fonction que je déchirais que je
définirais sommairement comme celle d'un
garde du corps
et si ils n'étaient pas habilités à
porter une arme pendant les déplacements
officiels
s'il n'en portait pas non plus pendant
les déplacements privés pourquoi la
présidence de la république et les
services du ministère de l'intérieur qui
ont instruit cette demande
ont-elles favoriser l'obtention d'un
permis de port d'armes
il ya là est pour nous une sorte d'
incohérences qu'elle pouvait être
l'utilité pour la présidence de la
république que cet agent est un permis
de port d'armes
non j'ai oublié de vous êtes présent de
me relancer sur la question du port
d'armes qui est des questions et que je
n'ai pas répondu et à laquelle je dois
commencer par répondre que je n'ai pas
eu à connaître de la question du port
d'armé d'alexandre benalla simplement
parce que comme je vous l'indiquais
compte tenu des responsabilités qui sont
les miennes je ne pourra revivre deux
questions même si encore une fois je
pense que ce sont des questions qui ne
relèvent pas du champ de cette
commission en tout cas qui relèvent très
clairement de l'organisation interne des
services de la présidence de la
république mais en tout état de cause je
n'ai pas eu à connaître de 7
de l'attribution des modalités
d'attribution de port d'armes à monsieur
benalla mais aussi bien me semble-t-il
le préfet de police que le directeur de
cabinet est présent dans le public vous
on vous en répondu sur ce point est à la
fois dans les modalités de l'attribution
par la préfecture de police donc du
cadre juridique dans laquelle
s'inscrivent et il me semble que ce
cadre e juridiques et liées à la
fonction et non pas lorsque si ç'avait
été une attribution par le ministère de
l'intérieur liés un risque le concernant
tout particulièrement et ça n'était pas
le cas de nos buts et justement et
qu'est ce qui dans sa fonction rendait
utile pour la présidence de la
république que monsieur bénard est un
permis de port d'armes
franchement je je suppose tout
simplement que comme vous l'avait
indiqué le dispositif de sécurité est
adapté à l'intensité de la de la menace
et au contexte dans lequel se situe
présente la république il est toujours
j'insiste il est tout à fait il y à des
services et ce sont toujours ces
services qui sont en charge
c'est toujours le gspr qui est en charge
lorsque le président l'a public est en
déplacement
je pense simplement je suppose que dans
certaines circonstances il a été jugé
qu' il pouvait être utile que d'autres
puissent apporter leur concours
mais vous les interrogez il n'en reste
pas moins j'insiste sur ce point
monsieur le sénateur parce que vous avez
l'air de trouver ça curieux mais c'est
ainsi c'est toujours le j'espère qu'ils
aient sur la protection présenta en
public le chef de jesper cela dit il y a
eu une mise à pied à l'endroit de
monsieur ben alors début mai c'est donc
une sanction vous même qui avait parlé
d'une faute je ne savais pas jusque là
que la sanction appelée récompense
je lis sur le fac similé de la
déclaration qu'a fait monsieur benalla
auprès de l'administration fiscale
attestant son changement d'un dress ce
changement d adresse qui prend effet le
9 juillet indique 11 quai branly j'ai
donc il ya quand même un problème n'est
ce pas il a été récompensé il a eu son
appartement on ce quai branly puisque il
fait un changement d'avis deuxièmement
je voudrais faire une rectification
quand même il ya j'ai posé la question
sur la suspension du traitement de
monsieur benalla et votre votre collègue
monsieur tron a répondu que les 15 jours
de suspension feront l'objet d'une
retenue sur les droits à congés qu'ils
avaient en reliquat au titre de l'année
2010 est pourtant il me semble que les
tests les textes applicables sont
claires j'ai fait vérifier
je cite un congé non pris ne donne pas
lieu à ne donne lieu à aucune indemnité
compensatrice
comment monsieur benalla peut-il ainsi
percevoir une indemnité compensatrice
pour des congés non payés
je vous donne une petite indication au
cas où ils seraient licenciés pour faute
lorsqu'on est licencié pour faute un
contractuel public
enfin lorsqu'on contractuels et licencié
cela n'ouvre pas normalement droit au
versement ni d'une indemnité de
licenciement ni même à une indemnité
compensatrice de congés annuels est ce
que monsieur benalla a été licencié pour
faute maintenant
n'est ce pas et de telles indemnités
lyon elle était versée
malgré cela n'est merci c'est une
question très précise monsieur de
secrétaire général
oui il ya deux questions il y en a une
sur le sur le logement et une sur sur le
licenciement
enfin sur la sur la sanction alors comme
jeu comme je vous le disais dans mon
propos enfin dans leur réponse à la
première question je ne
la gestion interne du personnel de
l'elysée relève de la responsabilité du
dialogue cabinet il me me rends compte
donc je ne cherche pas du tout l'esquivé
la moindre responsabilité mais je ne
suis pas intervenu
et je n'interviens pas dans
l'attribution des logements à la à la
résidence de de l'alma dont je crois
d'ailleurs le la liste est assez
largement diffusé et qui est qui en fait
accueil très majoritairement mais la
cour des comptes a déjà écrit
abondamment sur ce sur ce sujet des
personnes qui sont ils font l'objet
d'une nécessité absolue de de service
c'est-à-dire dont la les exigences de
disponibilité sont sont particulièrement
fortes
donc je ne suis pas intervenu dans
l'attribution du logement et donc je ne
reviendrai pas sur ce que le directeur
de cabinet a pu vous dire sur cette
question et
fiscale qui atteste changement mais je
fais le 9 juillet 2018
je j'entends bien je vous dis simplement
que je n'ai pas eu à connaître de
l'attribution de ce logement et de très
franchement je ne je ne je ne connais
pas les détails de cette de cette
attribution
ah ben oui je vous le dis très
directement je ne m'occupe pas et très
franchement je pense que il est logique
encore une fois je reviens sur cette
question de hiérarchie des
responsabilités
je fais beaucoup de choses je peux vous
dire je travaille un petit peu mais je
ne m'occupe pas de l'attribution de tous
les logements au sein de l'elysée fût ce
à monsieur benalla donc je m'en voudrais
vous donner une information erronée sur
ce sujet qui ne serait qu'une
information rapportée ce sur effet sur
la date la taille de l'appartement où
effectivement
et pour ce qui est de son delà de la
sanction
je reviendrai simplement sur la la
séquence qui est que au moment où la
section la sanction est prise
il y à un avertissement avec pouvant
conduire à un licenciement mais de la
décision du licenciement
elle n'est pas prise à ce moment là bien
évidemment donc on considère que la
sanction est appliquée pour des raisons
de sécurisation juridique sur lequel je
reviens pas lié au terme de deux
suspensions et les nécessités d'un
assurer la robustesse la retenue le
directeur salaires s'est révélé trop
fragile et du coup la sanction à la
retenue sur salaire la modalité de
retenue a pris la forme d'une annulation
quelque sorte qu'ils de retenue de jours
de congé et ce quand à son licenciement
oui c'est un cetain c'est à la suite
d'une nouvelle faute effectivement qu'il
a été qu'il a été licencié dans un cadre
juridique
j'ai passé la journée du 1er mai ou du
raw pour travailler mais aussi pour
suivre les différentes manifestations
qui se déroulaient sur le territoire
national et notamment la manifestation
qui se déroulait à paris qui avait été
annoncé comme une manifestation à haut
risque ceci pour me permettre d'informer
le secrétaire général de l'elysée et le
chef de l'état qui vous le savez à ce
moment là se trouvait en australie et
était sur le point de se rendre en
nouvelle calédonie j'ai appris le
lendemain matin c'est à dire le 2 mai au
cours de ces manifestations qui
s'étaient déroulé à paris et cours
desquelles de nombreux incidents se sont
produits un chargé de mission des
services de l'elysée plus précisément du
cabinet avait eu un comportement
inapproprié et choquant je les ai appris
qu on
prenant connaissance d'une vidéo qui n'a
été montrée par un collaborateur le
matin en arrivant au bureau vers les 9
heures et cette vidéo montre est à la
fois des scènes d'affrontements violents
avec des des poursuites entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre
des jets de projectiles qui visiblement
n'émanait pas des forces de l'ordre et
tout ceci dans une très grande confusion
et en même temps une scène de
l'intervention de policiers au sein
desquelles se trouvaient ceux chargés
mission qui semble être monsieur benalla
j'ai donc immédiatement convoqué
l'intéressé pour lui demander de de
s'expliquer et il m'a confirmé qu'il
était bien présent sur les lieux que
c'est bien lui qu'on voyait sur cette
vidéo
et il a justifié son comportement en
indiquant qu' il voulait aider les
policiers pris à partie par des
manifestants violents qui est qui
jetaient des projectiles sur les forces
de l'ordre
je les ai informés que sa participation
à cette opération de maintien de l'ordre
ne faisait pas partie de sa mission
d'observateurs et que son comportement
était inacceptable que cela constituait
une faute et qu'une sanction serait
prise j'ai immédiatement porté ces
informations à la connaissance du
secrétaire général de l'elysée pour
qu'il en informe le chef de l'état lors
du point quotidien que font le chef de
l'état et le secrétaire général lorsque
le chef de l'état est en déplacement
à l'étranger le secrétaire général on a
informé le chef de l'état en indiquant
qu un collaborateur
monsieur benalla avait eu un
comportement fautif et qu'une sanction
serait prise j'ai pris en tant que
directeur de cabinet directeur des
services de la présidence
la sanction qui comporte une suspension
de 15 jours sans traitement
c'est à dire une mise à pied une
exclusion temporaire du service
une autre sanction qui est la
modification des missions qui était
confiée à monsieur benalla en lui
retirant sa participation à
l'organisation des déplacements publics
du président de la république c'est à
dire très clairement mesdames et
messieurs une rétrogradation
et tout ceci a fait l'objet d'une lettre
que je lui est notifiée le 3 mai et qui
précisait également que en cas de
nouveaux comportements fautifs
il s'ensuivrait un licenciement certains
considèrent que ces sanctions n'étaient
pas adaptés et votre commission monsieur
le président ne permettra de vous
apporter toutes les réponses sur ce
point en cet instant je voulais
également dire que je mesure
parfaitement le trouble que le
comportement de ce collaborateur a pu
susciter notamment chez nos forces de
sécurité c'est pourquoi je
voudrait dire devant vous parce que je
sais que vous partagez cette
appréciation que le chef de l'état
mesure chaque jour l'engagement des
forces de sécurité pour assurer notre
sécurité au quotidien pour lutter contre
la menace terroriste
pour garantir le maintien de l'ordre est
donc garantir l'état de droit je voulais
le dire et dire également aux forces de
sécurité au nom du chef de l'état que la
sécurité du chef de l'état ne peut être
assuré que sous l'autorité et le
contrôle des policiers et des gendarmes
ce qui s'est passé mesdames et messieurs
c'est un comportement individuel fautif
pour lequel une information judiciaire
est ouverte et pour lequel une sanction
disciplinaire a été immédiatement prises
il appartient à présent à la justice
d'établir les responsabilités des
individus poursuivis et donc j'ai la
volonté en me présentant devant vous de
répondre de manière précise et complète
à toutes vos questions
fortil une arme at il des oreillettes
pour s'exprimer et un système de
communication une boucle mais il n'est
pas une bataille en sécurité ils
n'assurent pas la sécurité rapprochée la
callas comment dire il n'est pas garde
du corps du président de la république
monsieur benalla ne portait jamais tarn
lorsque il était dans un déplacement
public du président de la république
une information très importante
monsieur alors c'est sûr ainsi tu as
tendance à se faire et puis je vous
donne la parole de se dire je n'ai pas
parlé tout à l'heure dans le micro jeudi
ce qui est ma conviction j'entends
vraiment les explications que vous
donnez et chacun se fera un jugement -
la situation est complexe mais je
persiste à penser c'est peut-être torche
persiste à penser monsieur le directeur
que pour les manifestations notoire
internationalement un film est
extrêmement visible et de surcroît
sensibles qui ont suivi la sanction de
15 jours de mise à pied
et alors que les faits donc été ce que
vous savez il lui était possible de
confier cette mission à d'autres
personnes au sein de la bd et services
de la république française c'est tout et
puis j'assiste à dire je le dis
publiquement a dit l'auteur mais merci
et donc vous allez pouvoir répondre mais
j'ai une chose quand même
vous venez de nous dire que monsieur ben
alla ne portait jamais d'armes quand il
accompagnait le président de la
république dans un déplacement officiel
donc son permis de port d'armes était
exclusivement destinée à lui permettre
de porter une arme pour les déplacements
privés
ce n'était pas précisée dans
l'autorisation et d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si il a été amené à porter une arme
dans les déplacements privés
j'ai dit que je sais ce que j'ai dit
pourquoi at il demandé et obtenu un
permis de port d'armes si ils
n'emportaient jamais ce n'était pas dans
l'utilité du service alors je je ne j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure que en tant que
responsable direct de la sécurité du
chef de l'état il m'a paru à moi utile
que dans certaines circonstances il y
ait en plus du gspr qui est chargé de la
protection rapprochée
une personne qui puisse la voir non
c'est tout je ne peux pas j'ai voulu
comprendre et expliquer dans le détail
comment s'organise la sécurité du chef
de l'état en revanche je voudrais
répondre à une question très importante
lorsque vous avez fait est un des
relations tumultueuses entre monsieur
benalla et certains membres du gspr j'ai
noté des termes très forts ils il
terrorisait c'est bien ça on sait il
syndicales et des rapports exécrables
un syndicaliste sadisme voilà alors
plusieurs pour moi ce sont des dés pour
moi ce sont des termes extrêmement fort
et ils me surprennent
parce que le le colonel lavergne qui
commande le gspr je le vois tous les
jours tous les jours je fais le point
est cuit
jamais il n'a signalé ce type de
tensions
deuxièmement les agents du gspr je les
croise tous les jours je j'essaie
d'avoir ton rôle de chef du personnel
des relations je dirais direct avec tous
les agents que je croise la l'elysée que
vous connaissez monsieur le président et
une maison où il ya une proximité entre
les agents on se croise on se voit donc
s'il y avait eu des problèmes de ce type
des problèmes relationnels qui
pourrissent la vie au travail
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en a jamais parlé
je suis quand même surpris
de ce type d'informations je vous
remercie verrons dans les prochains
jours si ses propos sont étayés par des
faits plus précis je les deux
rapporteurs ont posé l'ensemble des
questions qui voulait poser à ce stade
donc je vais demander à monsieur
françois pilet de s'exprimer merci au
président une foule directeur l'article
11 je vais changer un peu de terrain
l'article 11 de la loi de 2013 relative
à la transparence de la vie publique
oblige les collaborateurs du président
de la république a déposé une
déclaration d'intérêts et à la
transmettre à l'autorité hiérarchique
dans la déclaration d'intérêts qui vous
a été transmise par monsieur benalla et
il fait mention de savon par définition
ce qu'il y a dans une déclaration
d'intérêts at-il fait mention de
relations particulières avec des
sociétés de sécurité privées ce
directeur ou vous évoquez la dérive dans
sa déclaration d'intérêts qui doit être
transmis à la haute autorité
oui voilà et aux supérieurs
hiérarchiques
il n'a pas fait alors nous sommes en
train d'expertiser ce point juridique
avant avant même le le cabinet de du du
président monsieur macron seuls les
conseillers dont la nomination était
publiée au jo
adressé une déclaration à la haute
autorité
et donc nous avons maintenu cette
pratique pour le cabinet qui est en
place depuis un an
donc monsieur men à la haye temps chargé
de mission ils n'étaient pas d'après
cette interprétation mais qui est ancien
il n'était pas tenu de faire cette
déclaration nous nous avons ce matin
demandé au secrétaire général du
gouvernement d'expertisé ce point c'est
à dire est ce que les chargés de mission
nous en avons neuf dans les effectifs de
l'elysée sont également tenus de faire
cette déclaration la haute autorité et
dès que nous aurons la réponse on se
pliera évidemment à ce qu'il faut faire
merci monsieur directement depuis les
rendements de la parole mais je pense
que l'interprétation juridique est assez
aisé à faire l'article 1 alinéa 4 de la
loi de 2013 précise bien que tous les
collaborateurs du président de la
république doivent déposer non seulement
une déclaration d'intérêts mais une
déclaration de patrimoine
là où la loi ne distingue pas et a pas
lieu de distinguer mais si nous voulons
distinguer il suffit de se reporter aux
travaux parlementaires
or devant l'assemblée nationale au
départ
effectivement votre position exacte car
le texte prévoyait que seuls les
collaborateurs de l'elysée ayant fait
l'objet d'une nomination passé au
journal officiel était soumis à cette
obligation
c'était un amendement de monsieur
dosière qui a renoncé et l'amendement
qui a été retenu est précisément un
amendement qui ne permet aucune
ambiguïté sur l'analyse de la loi
l'amendement ligne sur touré qui dit
bien que tous les collaborateurs
de l'elysée sont soumis à la déclaration
d'intérêts et à la déclare son
patrimoine
il n'y a pas de difficulté qui doit vous
amener à saisir 36 spécialistes du droit
en ce domaine c'est à mon avis assez
clair c'est d'autant plus clair en
l'espèce que c'est pas chargés de
mission c'est le chef adjoint de cabinet
monsieur mène à la tente
il devait déposer une déclaration
d'intérêts c'est dommage nous ne serons
pas s'il a vu deux des relations avec
des entreprises de sécurité privées puis
beaucoup plus grave c'est que nous le
non-respect de ces obligations constitue
un délit qui punit de trois ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amendé
alors je ne voudrais pas dans l'avenir
que nous revenions sur les mêmes
critiques ou soupçon ou doute que la
commission denquête a eu à mon sens
toutes les autorités et fonctionnaires
qui à l'heure actuelle cette situation
sont obligés de faire application de
l'article 40 elle qu'on se mette cette
situation au procureur de la république
monsieur le directeur
merci monsieur monsieur le sénateur pour
ces éléments dans son contrat de
recrutement
monsieur benalla est recruté en qualité
de chargé de mission uniquement chargées
mission est pas et pas adjoint au chef
de cabinet il n'est pas chef adjoint du
cabinet il est adjoint au chef du
cabinet s'agissant de des éléments que
vous vous m'indiquer donc je les dis
nous avons tout de suite demandé aux
stagiaires du gouvernement quelle est la
ligne à suivre
évidemment on va se confirmer mais je
jeune homme bien le l'amendement de
monsieur touré alors vous allez me
détester chers collègues mais françois
puis l'est qui viennent de lever une
question extrêmement important de
demandes et il ne s'est pas exprimée
pendant toutes les auditions
pratiquement sauf une fois ou deux il
demande la parole vous m'autorisez la
lui donner alors je
mais vous la donne au chocolat merci
l'analyse que je viens de faire
a tout de même été partagée par le
président hollande dès l'apparition de
la loi de 2013 il avait donné
instruction à toucher chargé de mission
de déposer des déclarations
certes l'habitude après celle de perdus
alors nous en tenons là sur cette
question mais je crois que les services
de la présidence de la république
pourront remercier monsieur pilet de son
éclairage juridique qui est plus rapide
que la réponse que vous attendez du
secrétaire général du gouvernement
pourtant excellent lui aussi alors nous
passons maintenant à monsieur loïc hervé
pour une minute
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur de cabinet ma première
question sera pour vous monsieur le
président la commission des lois parce
que dans les documents que nous sommes
légitimes a demandé à l'elysée nous
pourrions avoir le la fiche de poste le
contrat de travail et la feuille de paye
du mois de mai de monsieur benalla s'ils
me veulent qu'il vienne me chercher a
dit le président de la république devant
les parlementaires de la majorité
hier soir la maison de l'amérique latine
je partage totalement l'analyse du
rapporteur sur le fait que ça pose un
certain nombre de problèmes d'ordre
constitutionnel mais néanmoins je pense
que des documents éclairerait de manière
intelligente les travaux de la
commission et je remercie le directeur
de cabinet s'il voulait bien nous les
transmettre sous votre autorité monsieur
le président la commission des lois mais
je vous remercie
j'espère ne pas avoir besoin d'utiliser
mon autorité comme vous dites monsieur
le directeur vous pourriez peut-être
donné des assurances à cet égard le
président je sais qu'elle puisse
traduire votre expression comme
signifiant que vous allez nous
transmettre ces documents
je vais
bien évidemment voir dans quelles
conditions je peux vous les transmettre
et je m'engage à vous faire une réponse
très je vous remercie monsieur hervé
s'est donc exprimé mathieu présidente
kaner est il disponible pour le faire
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
c'est un cabinet il ya des zones d'ombré
manifestement sur les responsabilités
exactes de monsieur benalla je vais pas
faire un contrôle d'opportunité mais je
n'ai jamais vu un tel niveau de
responsabilité un simple chargé de
mission de 26 ans je vous le dis dans
mes mon expérience ministérielle ce
qu'il portait relevé au moins d'un
membre gio entre guillemets et et
sûrement avec une expérience plus
assumer et donc je souhaite dire à cette
commission que au nom des commissaires
socialistes ici présents nous
sollicitons officiellement l'audition de
monsieur ben alla au sein de notre
commission denquête n'ont pas bien
évidemment sur la question judiciaire
qui relève uniquement dans la séparation
des pouvoirs de l'autorité judiciaire
sur les faits qui lui sont
éventuellement reprocher sur la
contrescarpe mais bien sûr ses fonctions
administratives auprès de monsieur
strzoda auprès du président de la
république sur ses différentes
responsabilités et donc je voulais
monsieur le président bat donc vous
confirmez mon intention au nom des
commissaires membres de cette commission
enquête et nous vous le confirmeront par
écrit dès ce soir je vous remercie
attendez vous une réponse de monsieur le
directeur du cabinet du président de la
république sur ce point je ne peux que
prendre la note de la demande de
monsieur le ministre et je fais la même
chose alors nous passons maintenant à
monsieur kerrouche merci monsieur le
président
on est ensuite c'est sur un petit peu
particulière depuis hier nous savons que
président de la république s'estime
responsable de de cette affaire il est
j'avais dire d'autant plus responsable
qu'il était intouchable c'est sans doute
les deux sont sans doute liées
donc il a su vous assumez et nous nous
nous assumons notre fonction qui est pas
de nous substituer à l'autorité
judiciaire mais bien de comprendre le
dysfonctionnement de au sein de l'elysée
qui pour le coup a vraiment eu un un
mode de un mode de fonctionnement
justement très disruptif alors j'ai
trois questions très rapide
vous avez parlé du changement de mission
de monsieur de monsieur benalla est ce
qu'il y a une une note lui signifiant
son changement de mission et est ce que
cette noté est disponible et peut nous
être communiqué ses directeurs
la réponse est oui monsieur le sénateur
merci la deuxième chose c'est que il y a
me semble-t-il au sein de l'elysée 1,1
pôles un pôle régalien et une
conseillère juridique est une magistrate
et je pense que dès que vous avez vu la
vidéo
les gars à à votre professionnalisme il
est évident que vous avez je pense
mesurer tout de suite la difficulté que
pouvait représenter cette cette affaire
là ma question est très simple
est ce que vous avez demandé à cette
magistrate
s'il fallait activer l'article 40
oui ou non et si si oui que vous at elle
dit et sinon pourquoi n'avez vous pas
fait et enfin dernier point rapidement
vous avez parlé de une dizaine de
chargés de mission est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire à peu près combien de
personnes sont dans la même situation
que monsieur benalla
au sein de l'elysée rebondir rebondir
sur le fait qu'effectivement il ya un
problème avec la transparence et le fait
qu'ils aient pas de déclaration à la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie politique de 2 c de ses
personnels est simplement souligné mais
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez que
vous êtes dans ce cas là un petit peu
enfin l'elysée tablait en contradiction
avec la politique de transparence qui
est la sienne et qu'elle a affirmé par
la première loi votée sous ce
quinquennat
merci monsieur le directeur monsieur le
sénateur donc sur la note de service qui
précise les nouvelles attributions de
monsieur benalla je prends évidemment
note de de cette demande et je ferai
nécessaire pour vous faire parvenir aux
seuls présidents ce document sur la
question concernant l'article 40 et le
conseil que j'aurais pu demander à la
conseillère justice non je n'ai pas
consulté la conseillère justice j'ai eu
voyez vous j'ai une haute opinion de la
séparation des pouvoirs et même une
personne qui travaille à m'écouter qui
est magistrate sur ces questions je ne
voulais pas avoir son avis d'autant plus
que la décision a été prise très vite
je rappelle que la décision a été prise
le 2 mai dans la journée dans la journée
et donc je j'ai expliqué dans quelles
conditions
j'ai pris cette décision sur quel
fondement quelle information je
disposais et je l'assumé pleinement
je n'avais pas besoin de conseils je
j'ai l'habitude de mounir h2 d'être le
témoin de ce type d'opérations de
maintien d'ordre lorsque j'étais préfet
de corse et surtout préfet de bretagne
j'ai eu à gérer des manifestations je
parle sous le contrôle de monsieur de
sénateurs des manifestations extrêmement
violente où il y avait de très
nombreuses
très nombreux affrontements mais très
violent très violent les des bonnets
rouges vous pouvez en parler j'ai eu à
prendre des décisions dans ces
circonstances j'ai fait des articles 40
je n'ai jamais hésité à faire des
articles 40
j'étais amené en faire et là je
considérais que avec ce que je voyais
avec ce que je savais ce qui s'était
passé le 1er mai je n'avais pas besoin
de prendre 35 conseil
j'ai assumé ma décision je l'aï prise
tout de suite les chargés de mission je
suis désolé monsieur le sénateur mais on
touche là l'organisation de l'elysée
lors réalisation de de son
fonctionnement et donc de l'activité du
président un public et si je détaillait
ces éléments je pense que je pourrais
atteinte au principe de séparation
monsieur le directeur je ne partage pas
votre point de vue d'ailleurs les
principaux collaborateurs du président
de la république ont des fonctions qui
sont parfaitement publiques et je ne
vois pas qu'il y ait la moindre raison
tiré du principe de séparation des
pouvoirs est de ne pas expliquer ce que
chauffe les faire une mission de la
présidence de la république
ça n'est pas un secret d'état et ça
n'est pas de la part de notre collègue
porter atteinte à la séparation des
pouvoirs que de poser ce type de
questions vous avez raison j'aurais dû
être plus précis déjà les chargés de
mission en question ne participent pas
ou n'ont pas vocation à participer à des
opérations d'observateur auprès de la
préfecture de police
et donc je considère que ça ne fait pas
partie du champ
de deux enquêtes qui m'amène de bambou
directeur là encore je me permets de
vous dire puisque vous êtes attaché à la
séparation des pouvoirs qu'il nous
appartient d'interpréter nous mêmes le
champ des compétences qui nous sont
dévolues par le vote du sénat
et comme vous avez pu le constater vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure ce champ
est extrêmement large
nous nous intéressons en réalité au bon
fonctionnement de l'état est de
craignons la confusion des pouvoirs nous
sommes nous aussi attentifs à la
séparation des pouvoirs nous pensons que
cette séparation des pouvoirs existe
aussi entre le président de la
république et le gouvernement entre les
collaborateurs du président de la
république et les hiérarchies des
administrations placé sous l'autorité
dès ministres et du premier ministre
et donc je me permets de vous dire que
cette interprétation que vous faites est
hautement contestable et que je ne la
partage en aucun cas alors si à la
réflexion vous acceptiez de répondre
plus précisément à la question de notre
collègue je crois que ce serait positif
dans le propos liminaire que j'ai pu
développer devant vous j'ai précisé que
j'étais ici avec l'autorisation du
président de la république et qu'il m'a
demandé d'être extrêmement attentifs au
respect du principe de séparation
j'ai été invité devant votre commission
qui est chargée de faire la lumière sur
les conditions dans lesquelles des
personnes n'appartenant pas aux forces
de sécurité intérieure ont pu ou peuvent
être associés à l'exercice de leurs
missions de maintien de l'ordre
les autres chargés de missions ne sont
pas concernés par ces missions auprès
d'eux des forces de l'ordre
je vous
oui oui oui c'est le sol c'est le seul
chargé de mission qui qui dans ses
fonctions au cabinet qui dans ses
fonctions au cabinet pouvait être
observateurs pouvaient être observateur
bien nous passons à madame benbassa si
elle le veut bien merci monsieur le
président et j'aurais aimé savoir
comment la vidéosurveillance sur
laquelle figure monsieur benalla vous
êtes arrivé et par quels moyens
et deuxièmement j'aurais voulu savoir g6
monsieur benalla était sous contrat
privé ou sous contrat de droit public
parce que s'il était sous contrat de
droit public
les sanctions ne soient d'un
fonctionnaire de ce genre enfin qui est
sous droit public va de l'avertissement
au blâme à l'exclusion temporaire de la
fonction la révocation
monsieur banal a été mis à pied avec
suspension de salaire de 4 à 19 mois et
du 4 au 19 mai cela correspond donc à
une exclusion temporaire est de plus de
trois jours avec suspension deux
traitements
or inc est une telle sanction
elle ne peut pas être prononcé avant de
réunir le conseil de discipline
est ce que le conseil discipline a été
réunie et deuxièmement il est payé s'il
a un contrat de droit
de droit public il a été payé par le
comptable public
est ce que l'agent comptable de l'elysée
peut nous produire les écritures
montrant que monsieur b d'alan à toucher
que la moitié de son traitement le mois
où il a été sanctionné
merci merci cher collègue monsieur le
directeur monsieur benalla a été recruté
en qualité d'agent contractuel c'est un
contrat de droit public et donc pour la
sanction nous avons effectivement fait
application du décret de 1986 qui
prévoient l'échelle des sanctions vous
l'avez rappelé madame la sénatrice
l'avertissement l'exclusion temporaire
et le licenciement
donc là la sanction de suspension de
quinze jours en fait c'est une exclusion
temporaire qui a été qui a été prononcée
qui a été prononcée le conseil de
discipline n'a pas été saisie parce que
nous n'avons pas de conseils de
discipline dans les services de l'elysée
est gelée indiqué ce qui a primé tendre
dans notre
décision c'était la rapidité prendre une
sanction immédiate adaptée et
proportionnée
ce qui a été fait la première question
c'était à oui tout à fait ats alors
excusez-moi je vais monsieur benalla a
touché pour le mois de mai
son salaire intégral en revanche en
revanche les 15 jours de suspension se
feront l'objet d'une retenue sur les
droits à congés qu'ils avaient en
reliques à au titre de l'année 2007
il arrive là il a de très nombreux jours
de congés auquel il a droit au titre de
l'année 2010 est et dans son solde avant
licenciement ces congés ne seront pas
payés mais monsieur le ministre l'état
donc sans trop de préliminaires
le préfet de police de paris et le
directeur de l'ordre public et de la
circulation monsieur gibelin ollières
indiqué devant l'assemblée nationale que
monsieur b dallas n'avait pas reçu
d'autorisation officielle de participer
en tant qu'observateur aux opérations de
maintien de l'ordre du 1er mai ils ont
également précisé que la qualité
d'observateur avait été accordée à
monsieur b dallas par monsieur laurent
simoneau chef d'état major adjoint la
direction de l'ordre public et la
circulation sans que le directeur
lui-même n'en et été averti première
question est il normal que ni le
ministre de l'intérieur ni préfet de
police ni même leurs cabines n en ait
été informé par ailleurs le ministère de
l'intérieur at-il dès le 2 mai diligenté
une enquête interne pour obtenir des
informations sur les conditions de
participation de monsieur benalla à les
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
en effet vous avez indiqué que monsieur
b dallas ne participait pas des forces
de police mais il était sur l'opération
de maintien de l'ordre
cela signifie donc il avait été autorisé
bré semblablement par quelqu'un qui
appartenait à ses forces de police et ça
signifiait également si on en croit tous
les syndicats qu'il devait avoir un rêve
en tant qu'observateur qui ne s'était
non pas occupé de lui donc
aviez-vous diligenté une enquête interne
et enfin dans la négative pourquoi ne
pas vous être inquiétés d'un tel
dysfonctionnement
monsieur le ministre d'état comme je
viens de le dire a réuni l'ensemble de
ses cadres a diligenté une enquête
enquête interne a demandé pourquoi lui
même n'avait pas été mise au courant
c'est dans ce cadre qu ensuite est
apparue la responsabilité d'un certain
nombre de cadres subalternes puisque
c'était en hiver ou au numéro 3 ou 4 qui
avait été prise la décision sans que le
préfet de police ne soit effectivement
informé de ce qui se passait c'est un
peu ces relations que le préfet de
police a décrit hier comme des copinages
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
le rapporteur pour l'instant pas
d'autres questions monsieur le
rapporteur s'il vous plaît merci à
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état je voulais vous poser
trois questions eux d'abord eu
s'agissant de l'application dû code de
procédure pénale vous avez dit hier que
il n'appartenait pas finalement au
ministre de l'intérieur d' appliquer
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
je voulais vous demander en vertu de
quels articles de la loi
vous pouvez faire cette affirmation
ensuite je peux comprendre que vous ayez
considérer qu'il revenait à d'autres
personnes qui avouent même de saisir la
justice devant la gravité évidente des
faits dont vous avez eu connaissance le
2 mai
donc vous avez saisi le directeur ou
votre ministère votre directeur de
cabinet a saisi le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république mais celui
ci n'a pas plus que vous même et pas
plus que le préfet de police saisi le
ministère de la justice le procureur de
la république ni d'ailleurs le
secrétaire général de l'elysée ni
d'ailleurs le chef de cabinet du
président de la république est ce que
vous ne vous êtes pas dit logiquement au
bout d'un moment il ya quand même
quelque chose qui ne va pas il y a
quelque chose de inacceptable et ça a
été dit depuis peu avec force
c'est à dire un personnage qui n'est pas
policier qui est connue qui se
comportent ainsi
ce qui à l'évidence et délictueux et
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur se
satisferaient du fait que personne
personne ne saisisse la justice c'est la
première question le ministre d'état
s'il vous plaît alors
monsieur le co-rapporteur j'ai
connaissance quotidiennement par des
notes de service de renseignement de
suspicion d'infraction pénale ou de
commission d'infractions pénales
je considère et j'ai toujours considéré
depuis mon arrivée au ministère de
l'intérieur
et comme tous mes prédécesseurs qu'il
n'appartient pas au ministre de
l'intérieur de transmettre au procureur
des signalements sur le fondement de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
à chaque fois qu'il a connaissance de la
commission d'une infraction pénale
ce n'est pas mon rôle de saisir chaque
procureur individuellement pour lui
signaler la commission d'infractions
je n'ai d'ailleurs transmis depuis ma
prise de fonction qu'un seul article 40
à la justice pour une infraction prévue
par la loi de 1881 de la presse il
concernait rappeur chez les dictateurs
dans une vidéo appelant aux lois salle
et au meurtre d'un policier
alors ces pratiques sont elles
simplement celle du ministre de
l'intérieur actuel non j'ai regardé
combien
et avait été fait de signalement par les
différents ministres et les différentes
années sur l'année 2014 monsieur soeur
et on avait 2 sur l'année 2015 y en
avait 4 sur l'année 2016 il en avait 8
sur l'année 2016 y aurait eu cap et là
il y en a eu un
et je regarde les différents mini ce
long il fait non monsieur hortefeux par
exemple qu'il y avait un cabinet qui
d'un point de vue juridique avait
quelques expériences effectuées au cours
de l'année seulement trois signalements
au titre de l'article 40 et elles se
portent toutes sur des problèmes de
droit de la presse ou bien d'incitation
à l'air
je comprends votre réponse monsieur le
ministre d'état vous considérez qu'il ne
nous appartient pas de faire vous même
ces signalements pour autant vous citez
quand même des cas où le ministre l'a
fait et vous avez un pouvoir est rare
chic et si l'un de vos collaborateurs
vous demande l'autorisation de faire un
signalement
vous pouvez être amené à la lui donner
mais je vous rappelle les termes de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
sans les commenter plus avant toute
autorité constituée je crois que vous
êtes bien une autorité constituée qui
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
acquiert la connaissance d'un crime ou
d'un délit est tenu d'en donner avis
sans délai au procureur de la république
est rude et de transmettre à ce
magistrat tous les renseignements procès
revêt beau et actes qui y sont relatifs
je dois vous dire que la commission des
lois se serait parfaitement accommodés
que cette utilisation de l'article 40 ne
viennent pas de votre fait
nous ne vous reprocheront pas de ne pas
l'avoir fait personnellement mais du
constatons que dans toute la hiérarchie
personne ne l'a fait alors que de
nombreux cadres dirigeants du ministère
de l'intérieur avait en main les
éléments permettant de caractériser
cette suspicion de délit c'est c'est
simplement cela qui est derrière la
question je l'interprète
être de notre collègue le président
sueur je veux vous rappeler que le
préfet de policé de directeur de cabinet
du président de la république avait été
informé de cette situation et donc qu'il
ne m'appartenait pas moi qui ne
connaissaient pas les circonstances
exactes puisque effectivement je n'ai
pas connaître de la façon dont est
dirigée la préfecture de police de
prendre effectivement cet article parce
que le ministre d'état que d'autres que
vous ai pu le faire c'est certain mais
que vous ne l'ayez pas fait pose quand
même question et si vous n'aviez pas les
informations nécessaires qui aurait été
mieux placé que vous pour les obtenir
alors maintenant si vous le permettez
monsieur le président je voulais vous
dire monsieur le ministre vous employez
beaucoup le verbe connaître à la forme
négative
vous ne connaissiez pas vous ne saviez
pas mais je vous rappelle quand même les
termes de ma question dès lors que vous
considérez c'est une interprétation qu
est la vôtre qu'il ne revient pas au
ministre de l'intérieur de saisir la
justice
pourquoi ne vous êtes-vous pas étonné
que à aucun niveau de la hiérarchie dans
l'elysée au ministère de l'intérieur à
la préfecture de police personne ne les
faits mais j'en viens à ma deuxième
question le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république vous dit
qu'il va y avoir une sanction à l'égard
de monsieur bénalia il ya donc une
sanction puisqu'il est suspendu
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
pour 15 jours et monsieur le porte
parole de l'elysée dit qu'à la suite de
la suspension
il a été démis de toutes missions
relatives à la sécurité et à la
protection du président de la république
donc conviés à donner sans doute à notre
poste
alors vous ne connaissiez pas le et vous
l'avez dit je vous crois je n'ai pas de
raison de ne pas vous croire monsieur le
ministre d'état le chef de cabinet
adjoint de l'elysée vous vous rendez
compte qu'il existe le 2 mai bien qu'il
soit sûr quand même beaucoup de photos
et que le ministère de l'intérieur
quelques pouvoirs d'investigation on est
d'accord
et vous dites vous vous faites votre
travail en informant monsieur le
directeur de cabinet du faso la
république
celui ci décide d'une sanction mais vous
êtes bien je pense que vous êtes
d'accord que quelqu'un qui tabasse des
citoyens quelles que soient les
circonstances
alors qu'il est déguisé en policier et
que ça relève de la justice
ça pose un problème est qu'on va pas
confier en effet des missions de
sécurité et de protection du chef de
l'état à ce personnage
or une fois qu'il a fini ses quinze
jours on le retrouve dans d'innombrables
situations on a parlé de l'arrivée des
cendres de simone veil -le au panthéon
on a parlé de la question de l'arrivée
des footballeur à paris où il est à 30
cm du chef de l'état et il est toujours
dans des missions de sécurité en tant
que ministre de l'intérieur
comment pouvez vous accepter cela et
avez vous fait des démarches pour pour
le moins vous étonné de cet état de
choses auprès de la présidence de la
république monsieur le ministre d'état
vous avez la parole un tueur d'abord si
vous voulez sur la connaissance de
monsieur benalla comme vous le savez
avant d'assurer la protection à un
moment donné de la campagne du président
de la république et la bassure et un
certain nombre de protections d'autres
campagnes suez du président hollande
de madame aubry et comme je m'étais un
peu éloigné du ps à cette époque je le
connaissais moins que d'autres et donc
voilà sur monsieur benalla sur l'article
le directeur de cabinet le prends pas ce
problème de dire excepté attendait
monsieur le ministre d'état on va
rétablir le calme vous avez nous avons
pardon monsieur le ministre d'état n'ont
pas mal joué sur mise et ajuste un
instant elle est ministre d'état
je voudrais que vous me laissiez le soin
que la commission puisse vous entendre
dans un climat de série de gorée qui
facilite nos travaux mes chers collègues
et vous ne manquerez pas d'avoir la
parole de manière concise je le répète
est donc vous pourrez à ce moment-là
réagir je comprends que les propos qui
viennent d'être tenus par le ministre
d'état ait pu faire bondir le président
du groupe socialiste
il aura l'occasion de dire pourquoi plus
tard mais je vous demande de bien
vouloir écouter le ministre d'état dans
sa réponse donc sur l'article 40
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la république vient de faire part donc
tout à l'heure à l'assemblée nationale
des éléments qui l'avait conduit à ne
pas saisir la justice de ces faits 1 le
contexte de violence et je vous rappelle
qu'elle un contexte de violence très
fort à la contrescarpe et 2 l'absence de
plein puisque les personnes qu'on voit
sur les photos avaient pris la fuite
donc à partir de là c'est son
appréciation d'autorité hiérarchique et
je n'ai évidemment pas à commenter
eh bien monsieur le musée de la marne
ont cessé le rapporteur je voudrais
essayer vaille que vaille de jouer mon
rôle de président le mieux possible et
donc à ce stade de notre audition se
sont écoulés 45 minutes je pense que
nous aurons jusqu'à 20h 22h15 pour aller
au bout les questions le ministre d'état
et disponibles pour répondre à toutes
les questions
il va essayer de le faire avec lui aussi
toute la concision nécessaire il s'agit
parfois de questions très factuelle et
donc ça lui facilitera la tâche
je voudrais demander à monsieur le
rapporteur s'il a une autre question
ayant le souci aussi de permettre à
l'ensemble de nos collègues de
s'exprimer monsieur alors ce sera très
concis mais je dirais cependant à
monsieur le ministre d'état qu'il n'a
pas répondu à ma question car ma
question c'est est que dès lors que les
15 jours de suspension on peut juger
comme on veut cette sanction c'est une
sanction elle n'était pas formalisé il
n'y a pas eu de procédure disciplinaire
mais une option mais que dès lors que
cette sanction était fini et est il
acceptable de confier des tâches de
sécurité auprès du chef de l'état à ce
personnage question simple monsieur la
tunise l'intérieur telle réponse
ce n'était pas directement le ministère
de l'intérieur qui avait à gérer
il y avait effectivement c'était en
général un certain nombre d'événements
que vous avez cités qui étaient des
événements parisiens ou d'ailleurs le
préfet de police a dit qu'il était amené
à pouvoir donc rencontré même pas son
niveau mais des niveaux inférieurs
celui qui s'occupait de ce genre
d'événement mais effectivement moi je
n'avais pas en connaît bien monsieur le
ministre de fureur et c'est votre
réponse et le temps a bien devoir s'en
satisfaire me sens utile croyez que ce
soit paris lui donnera bien traduites en
question est la même
enfin merci monsieur je leur sourit pour
moi la protection du président de la
république c'est le gspr permis le
j'espère ce sont des policiers des
gendarmes qui dépendent aussi de
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
bien sûr mais pour nous nous ne
connaissons qu'une seule qu'une seule
autorité pour gérer la production la
protection du président de la république
le j'espère merci mme a terminé attardé
sur le rapporteur vous aviez terminons
elle est très courte
3 mais elle est très courte
vous avez hier il ya eu beaucoup de non
réponse et certains ont pu dire que vous
étiez sans doute l'une des personnes les
moins informés de notre pays ce qui
n'est pas vrai et vous avez la
possibilité de convoquer vos
fonctionnaires et de procéder à toutes
les interrogations investigations que
vous voulez donc je reste sur ma faim
par rapport à quelques questions simples
qui a donné le statut d'observateur à
monsieur benalla qui lui a donné un
brassard de police qui vraiment qu'il a
autorisé à participer à des réunions de
commandement au plus haut niveau à la
préfecture de police
et enfin eux y qui lui a donné le port
d'armes qui quelle autorité quelle
personne concrètement et enfin c'est mon
dernier point monsieur le président vous
avez dit hier que s'agissant de cette
voiture extrêmement équipés et je dois
dire que nous avons reçu les personnels
de la police
et vous le savez très bien je ne vous en
fais pas grief qui nous ont pas ce que
c'est une situation ancienne qui nous
ont fait part de
du de l'état de certains véhicules tonka
véhicules super aménagé et vous avez dit
que des je ne sais pas qui a pris cette
décision de doter ce ce monsieur de cela
donc je pense que d'ici hier depuis hier
vous avez pu vous renseigner merci pour
les réponses précises que vous me l'a
rapportée aujourd'hui monsieur le
ministre d'état je vous redonne la
parole vous voyez c'est une seule
question avec un seul point
d'interrogation mais avec beaucoup de
virgules donc je vais y répondre comme
vous le savez il y a une double enquête
à la fois judiciaire et en même temps de
l'igpn qui apportera des réponses à ses
questions en tout cas ce que je peux
vous assurer c'est que tout ceci ne
vient pas du ministère de l'intérieur du
cabinet du ministre monsieur le ministre
d'état nous avons découvert à la sphère
benalla grâce à la vidéo protection les
images de la vidéo protection de paris
et d'une vidéo amateur on nous apparaît
dans les auditions précédentes de
l'existence de photos et de vidéos de
crs qui pourrait s'expliquer puisqu'il
était dans une position délicate place
de la contrescarpe nous avons d'abord
découvert
monsieur alexandre benalla nous avons
ensuite découvert le commando benalla
avec monsieur vincent kraz on nous parle
maintenant d'un accompagnant monsieur
misère ski encadrant nom officiel est ce
que ses photos et ses vidéos
vont-ils avant elle nous fait
redécouvrir pardon d'autres
protagonistes sur les lieux ce que vous
avez connaissance de ces photos et que
nous font-elles visionner et pour finir
je vous demanderais s'il existe une
milice privée au sein de l'elysée
or gspr merci chers collègues aussi de
votre concision monsieur le ministre
d'énergie pour ce qui concerne monsieur
misére ce qu'est un de ses supérieurs
hiérarchiques lui demande de
l'accompagner
monsieur benalla qu'il croyait après 10
t
facebook qu'il croyait à créditer je
pense mais l'anc est encore le montrera
pour participer à une opération de
maintien de l'ordre comme observateurs
beaucoup de députés de journalistes
participent à des opérations comme
observateurs elles sont strictement
encadrées le préfet de police l'a
rappelé hier ils souhaitaient que ce
soit elle l'a rappelé à ces cas son
autorisation personnels qu'ils soient
donnés
parce que cela engage effectivement sa
responsabilité
merci beaucoup monsieur mise d'état
madame jacky d'euromédis les ce qui va
sortir
compte tenu des deux ce qui se passe ou
les gens découvrent chaque jour sur les
personnalités
je lis les journaux comme vous et il ya
toute une partie de l'histoire de
monsieur benalla que franchement je
découvre de plus en plus eh bien
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
heureusement qu'il ya les journaux pour
vous informer
alors madame d'euromédis merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre le
porte parole de l'elysée a déclaré que
monsieur benalla avait été mise à pied
pendant quinze jours avec suspension de
salaire du 4 au 19 mai est entièrement
démis de ses fonctions en matière
d'organisation de la sécurité des
déplacements du président de la
république que faisait monsieur benalla
auprès du chef de l'état au panthéon
que faisait monsieur benalla à giverny
le vendredi 13 juillet alors qu'il avait
été déchargé de ses fonctions de chef
adjoint du cabinet sa présence dans le
quart des qui ramenait les bleus de
l'aéroport et est elle normale vous
paraît-il normal qu'il ait eu des
altercations avec les policiers qui
devaient assurer cette ce retour des
bleus au à la présidence monsieur le
ministre et a comme vous le savez la
nature démission de monsieur benalla ce
n'est pas moi qui les fixent donc je
pense que le directeur de cabinet du
président de la
public s'expliquera ou s'est déjà
expliqué sur l'ensemble des questions
que vous posez
merci monsieur mist état je me permets
simplement de souligner que monsieur
benalla et s'est établie s'agissant des
déplacements du président de la
république à paris étaient en contact
fréquent avec la préfecture de police ça
n'est certainement pas la préfecture de
police qui lui est assignée ses tâches
simplement les personnes avec lesquelles
il travaillait qui sont placés sous
votre autorité semble-t-il savait bien
ce qu'il faisait puisque elle
travaillait avec lui et par ailleurs je
suppose que les préfets les directeurs
départementaux de la police nationale
les officiers supérieurs commandant le
groupement de gendarmerie quand il y
avait un déplacement présidentiel et
qu'il avait à traiter avec monsieur
benalla soit pour la préparation soit en
sa qualité de garde du corps supposée
est vraisemblable traitait avec lui donc
quand on vous pose ce type de question
bien entendu que c'est pas vous qui
définit si sa tâche ça je crois que
c'est cette réponse nous pouvons que
vous en donner acte et simplement ce qui
nous intéresse c'est de savoir quel est
le regard porté par le ministère de
l'intérieur sur sept ce collaborateur
avec lequel vous acceptiez vos services
acceptaient de travailler sur
certainement des missions au précise cc
je crois sans vouloir sur interpréter
deux cents à la question de notre
collègue d'euromédis c'est une question
qui était purement purement factuel elle
ne vous dit pas pourquoi avez vous en
voyez monsieur benalla à giverny
mais elle vous demande est-ce que par
vos services vous avez une idée précise
de ce que monsieur benalla faisait à
giverny au nom du président de la
république met en lien avec des services
passés sous votre autorité
si je crois et excusez moi et si je me
trompe il faut arrêter tout de suite
monsieur le président mais en plus si
vous voulez je voudrais quand même il ya
une partie qui vous concerne directement
ses les altercations qu'il a eu avec les
policiers parce qu'il voulait reprendre
le contrôle du retour des bleus
donc donc souci vous aurez vous avez
certainement été informés alors monsieur
miss d'état cette question et en étant
maintenant éclaircies monsieur le
président je travaille pour ce qui me
concerne avec les préfets qui ont la
responsabilité avec le directeur général
de la police nationale avec le directeur
général de la gendarmerie nationale et
donc je ne franchis pas cet échelon
c'est à eux d'organiser les choses comme
il le souhaite
et pour répondre à votre question le
préfet de police m'a indiqué qu'il
n'était pas informé il n'aurait jamais
je crois qu'il l'a dit dans l'audition
qu'ils n'auraient jamais laissé prendre
le contrôle de la manifestation de
retour des bleus à quelqu'un à à
quelqu'un qui soit extérieur à ses
services à lui merci monsieur le
ministre d'état monsieur pierre yves
collombat pour une minute
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre d'état a manifestement
alexandre benalla était au ministère de
l'intérieur comme un poisson dans l'eau
un poisson plutôt carnivores d'ailleurs
semble-t-il personne ne sait qui il est
vraiment très peu concède même le
connaître
et pourtant on larmont l'équipe il
s'impose dans des opérations de maintien
de l'ordre et aux séances de débriefing
avec pour seul viatique sa réputation
d'appartenir au cabinet du président de
la république
ma question est celle-ci au final qui a
la haute main sur les services de police
et de gendarmerie en france vous
deuxième personnage de l'état dans le
respect des lois du goût du gouvernement
est donc dans le respect des lois et
règlements ou le président de la
république qui semble auto placer au
dessus des lois et les règlements qui
gouvernent ou où le président de la
république qui par son influence modifie
les comportements au sein du ministère
de l'intérieur
merci chers collègues bravo pour votre
concision monsieur le ministre d'état
merci bien je viens de l'indiquer à
l'instant lorsque je fais des
débriefing comme vous dites c'est avec
les préfets nous en faisons à peu près
une tous les mois est en ce moment pour
les problèmes de terrorisme
nous faisons des débriefings avec les
préfets de zone tous les quinze jours
nous le faisons avec les directeurs de
la police nationale des directeurs de la
gendarmerie le directeur de la dgsi et
cela s'arrête là pour ce qui me concerne
je n'ai d'autre débriefing avec personne
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
di folco merci monsieur le président
monsieur ministre d'état une réponse une
question très courte qui appelle une
réponse très précise
qu'auriez vous fait si l'elysée n'avait
pas indiqué réagir aux comportements
pour le moins incongru de monsieur
benalla que l'on nous vend être un
observateur voir un bagagiste merci des
folkeux je me suis simplement assuré que
le directeur de cabinet de l'elysée
avait bien pris en compte l'attitude
inacceptable de monsieur benalla et le
directeur de cabinet indiqué qu'un
certain nombre de sanctions seraient
pris partir de là c'était la sphère du
directeur de cabinet parce que c'est lui
qui organise celles et ceux qui sont
effectivement conseillé ce n'est pas au
ministre de l'intérieur d' organiser le
fonctionnement des conseillers de
l'elysée
merci monsieur le ministre d'état madame
brigitte lherbier
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre j'aurais voulu vous
poser une question concerne non
justement
les agents contractuels qui contribuent
à la sécurité des déplacements du chef
de l'état j'aurais voulu savoir si
c'était une occasion à cette occasion si
vous avez fait l'inventaire de tout ce
qui était employé at elle la présidence
at-elle recours aux services de
militants deux collaborateurs de la
république en marche pourquoi pas pour
contribuer à l'organisation ou à la
sécurité des déplacements du président
de la république
c'est une occasion de faire le point un
peu de sur le nombre sur le genre de
collaboration que les uns et les autres
peuvent avoir dans ce genre d'affairé ce
ministére moi comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le rappeler
tout à l'heure il y a qu une seule
autorité compétente avec et nous
traitons le gspr merci monsieur le
ministre d'état c'est votre réponse
monsieur à la marque
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je vais réitérer un petit
peu la question de notre président
philippe bas parce que nous avons
auditionné tout à l'heure des syndicats
de police et des syndicats de police un
membre de ce syndicat nous a affirmé que
monsieur benalla n'était pas tout seul
et qu'il était souvent accompagnée de
barbouzes jeu reprend les termes qui ont
été employés dans certaines émissions
vous nous avez dit qu'a priori il n'y
avait pas de police parallèle voir 2010
comme l'a dit ma collègue précédemment à
l'elysée si dans les jours qui viennent
la preuve était apportée par ces mêmes
syndicats et venant du gspr qui
apparemment était terrorisée par
monsieur benalla et qui aujourd'hui se
livre est-ce que vous trouveriez ça
normal deuxièmement monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur miss d'état 1er mai on
sait ce qui se passe
mises à pied jusqu'au 19 mai et vous qui
êtes le premier flic de france donc la
personne qui normalement devait
pratiquement tout connaître
est-ce que vous avez diligenté une
enquête pour savoir si monsieur benalla
qui se targuait déjà de posséder un
master de droit alors je ne sais trop si
c'est vrai savoir si son casier
judiciaire judiciaire était était vierge
au poste qu'il occupait puisque la
fonction qu'effectivement il occupe et
la continuer d'ailleurs à occuper
pouvait peut-être pourquoi pas me lasser
à terme la sécurité du président de la
république monsieur le ministre d'état
je regrette c'est des syndicats de
police ont pu vous faire cette
déclaration qu'il ne me l'ait pas fait à
moi parce que je les rencontre assez
souvent
nous discutons de l'ensemble des
problèmes et donc jamais ils ne m'ont
fait remonter de dysfonctionnements avec
monsieur benalla que jusqu'à une date
récente je vous le rappelle je pensais
qu'il était un policier
jamais on ne m'a fait remonter ceux ci
après est ce que et à des équipes de
barbouzes pour ce qui concerne le
ministère de l'intérieur
il n'y aura jamais de barberousse
quelque part parce que effectivement
c'est quelque chose que je n'admettrai
pas je voudrais maintenant vous posez la
question du port d'armes
c'est une situation assez singulière
vous avez rappelé vous-même que une
demande tu crois de me demande même
avait été adressée au ministre de
l'intérieur que ces demandes n'ont pas
obtenu une réponse favorable mais que le
préfet de police lui a délivré le port
d'armes est ce qu'il est réellement
possible que la préfecture de police qu
n'est pas informée ni le cabinet ni les
services centraux du ministère de
l'intérieur de la délivrance d'un permis
de port d'armes ou un collaborateur du
président de la république dont on a
suffisamment souligné ces derniers temps
que sa seule qualité de collaborateur du
président de la république faisait
impression
sur des agents de la police nationale
et je suppose que donc elle pouvait
faire impression aussi sur les services
centre de la préfecture de police comme
du ministère au fond il ya une sorte de
discordance entre les l'affirmation
selon laquelle la préfecture de police
aurait agi seul et le contexte général
qu'on a souvent décrit devant cette
commission
monsieur le président comme est qu un
blaireau qui est dans mon propos
liminaire je n'ai pas été informé comme
le ministre lui même a pu vous le dire
de la délivrance le 13 octobre 2010 est
d'une autorisation de port d'armes par
monsieur bénard pour monsieur b alors si
on fait un peu dark d'archéologie une
certaine information atteste que
monsieur benalla avait déjà demandé la
possibilité de tenir un port d'armes
pendant la campagne de l'élection
présidentielle est ce que comme
directeur de cabinet plutôt directeur de
campagne du candidat emmanuel macron
vous pouvez confirmer cette information
je peux vous confirmer que monsieur
benalla disposait dans port d'armes dans
le cadre d' allah de la campagne
présidentielle
uniquement dans les locaux du siège de
la campagne
savez vous si la porter cette arme en
dehors des locaux du siège de la
campagne
pas à ma connaissance je vous remercie
et je vais donner la parole maintenant à
monsieur le président en sueur merci
monsieur le président je voulais eux
monsieur chef de cabinet vous poser deux
questions sur l'actualité récente
le journal libération a publié un
article et des vidéos faisant état d'
événement survenu trois
avant les événements de la contrer ce
cas et mettant en cause monsieur benalla
et monsieur kraz avez vous connaissance
de ces événements quand et si vous ne
veut pas eu connaissance comment
l'expliquez vous je n'ai pas eu
connaissance de ces éléments avant de
lire tout comme vous l'article de
libération et de découvrir les quelques
secondes de vidéo qui témoignerait de
l'intervention de monsieur benalla et
monsieur kraz il y apparaît en éléments
nouveaux que je n'avais pas vu jusqu'à
présent c'est le port d'un brassard par
monsieur kraz au delà je ne disposais
pas de cette information et au regard de
précédentes auditions qui ont pu avoir
lieu
les autorités de la préfecture de police
lors de premières auditions elles mêmes
n'ont pas semblé avoir à leur
connaissance une intervention préalable
à celle de la contrescarpe merci le
deuxième question de monsieur benalla a
obtenu dans les conditions que l'on sait
une vidéo présentant les événements qui
l'ont précédé son intervention
cette vidéo aurait été transmise à un
conseiller du président de la république
avez vous eu connaissance de cette vidéo
et quand en possédez vous une copie ou
quelqu'un du cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur en peau s'est-il une copie à
votre connaissance concernant cette
vidéo dont vous connaissez les
conditions dans laquelle elles ont été
obtenues
je tiens à affirmer que personne au
syndic du cabinet du ministre d'état n'a
eu connaissance de cette vidéo il n'a vu
cette vidéo
nina transmis ou posséder cette vidéo
sous une quelconque forme
au delà je crois que ces informations
sont désormais couvertes par le secret
de l'instruction et il appartiendra à la
justice de faire toute la lumière sur
ces fonds je vous remercie enfin eu une
troisième question avant de donner le
relais à ma collègue interrogé le 24
juillet par notre commission monsieur le
ministre d'état gérard collomb a déclaré
vous concernant et s'agissant du
recrutement de monsieur benalla eux au
sein de la campagne présidentielle
je cite entre guillemets je ne pense pas
qu'il c'est à dire vous même et recruter
monsieur vénale a sinon il y aurait un
problème de confiance et verriers et le
jeu n'a pas changé ajoute une phrase
avec la permission du président pouvez
vous confirmer donc que vous n'avez pas
recruter monsieur benalla alors qu'on
avait cru comprendre le contraire
dans ces conditions comment s'est
effectuée exactement son traitement et
enfin avez-vous joué un rôle dans son
recrutement ultérieure à la présidence
de la république j'en ai fini monsieur
messier gériez très bien alors pour vous
répondre sur vos différentes questions
tout d'abord recruter alexandre b n'a
lâché en marche
je n'ai pas recruter alexandre benalla
pour une raison bien simple d'abord les
recrutements étaient effectués par le
trésorier de la campagne les différents
chefs de pôles qui organisait cette
campagne présidentielle trois pôles
grand pôle affaires générales en pôle
communication est en pôle opérations et
événementiel en l'occurrence la sécurité
dépend des du pôle opérations monsieur
benalla a été recruté en décembre 2016
or à ce moment là je n'avais pas
aptitude à recruter quiconque seul car
monsieur benalla a été recruté en
décembre et j'ai pris mes fonctions de
directeur de campagne au 1er janvier
comme je voulais dit en introduction
néanmoins je tiens elles vont être
parfaitement précis et je confirme avoir
été à vie
et de son embauche car j'étais alors le
chef de cabinet de la campagne comme
cela apparaît d'ailleurs dans un
courriel qui est issu des piratages des
boîtes email de la campagne
présidentielle
nous avons une mention vu avec jm g sur
la deuxième question c'est qu'est celle
de la confiance
vous connaissez les relations qui sont
celles d'un élu avec son collaborateur
d'un ministre avec son collaborateur
elles sont fondées sur un lien de
confiance j'avais donné cette
information au ministre d'état dès lors
il considère que nous sommes en
confiance lorsque je lui transmets cette
information je travaille dans son
environnement auprès de lui depuis
bientôt une dizaine d'années et je ne
doute pas du lien de confiance qui est
le nôtre
eu égard à mon engagement et ma loyauté
pour terminer et répondre sur le
troisième point je n'ai pas été saisi et
je crois tout simplement que je n'avais
pas mon mot à dire sur le recrutement de
monsieur benalla au palais de l'elysée
j'étais alors à beauvau en qualité de
chef de cabinet et je n'ai pas à porter
un quelconque jugement ni un quelconque
regard sur les recrutements qui sont
effectués à la présidence de la
république
merci merci monsieur verrier et madame
jourda
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure monsieur gériez
avoir revu monsieur benalla au cours de
réunions ou de visites préparatoires
quel était son rôle de revoir monsieur
vénale à à l'issue de la période durant
laquelle il a fait l'objet d'une
suspension
j'ai eu l'occasion pour vous donner les
derniers exemples que j'ai en tête de
traiter avec lui de question de pure
protocole de placements dans les
tribunes officielles pour le défilé de
14 juillet d'accès ou d'organisations
périmétrique au palais de l'elysée pour
la venue de l'équipe de france de
football
je n'ai eu dans ce cadre là que des
relations
et au nouveau périmètre qui était le
sien en l'occurrence celui de la gestion
d'événements relevant du palais de
l'elysée madame jourdain
vous n'avez jamais occasion donc de
travailler avec lui antérieurement cette
rétrogradation
je vous répondais sur la période à
l'issue auparavant dès son arrivée au
mois de mai j'ai bien évidemment eu
l'occasion de travailler à de multiples
reprises avec lui dans les nombreux
déplacements qu'a pu effectuer le
ministre d'état avec le président de la
république madame chantal donc quel
était son rôle dans ces rôles et c'est
monsieur benalla dans ses réunions dans
ses visites préparatoires ou dans ses
déplacements avaient en rôle de
chefferie de cabine est assez classique
organisation gestion des espaces gestion
des flux gestion du protocole relation
avec la préfecture relation avec les
interlocuteurs institutionnels du
territoire et dans une visite
préparatoire vous savez nous sommes
assez nombreux
la visite préparatoire et mener dirigé
par un membre de la chefferie de cabinet
et l'ensemble des services concourant
sont présents le ministère concerné
lorsque c'est le cas mais aussi les
services de presse de communication de
réalisation de sécurité ou d'intendance
la bourde a le rôle qu'y joue alors avec
quelque chose à voir pour vous avec la
sécurité non le rôle de monsieur benalla
n'avait rien à voir avec l'organisation
du dispositif de sécurité
mais l'organisation globale général du
déplacement
une vidéo tournée la veille a été très
largement diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux où elle a été vue plus de 100
mille fois plusieurs salariés de la
république en marche nous ont vus ils
ont été stupéfaits dit reconnaître un de
leurs collègues
en l'occurrence vincent kra ce qu'ils
connaissent bien puisqu'il est l'un des
agents en charge de l'accueil de la
sécurité du siège la réplique en marche
ils ont également reconnu pour certains
d'entre eux alexandre benalla que
certains avaient pu croiser durant la
campagne présidentielle
j'ai été informé ce même jour le 2 mai
aux alentours de 18 heures alertée j'ai
alors visionner sur mon téléphone cette
vidéo présente dans les locaux de la
république en marche à cette heure là
j'y arrivais j'ai souhaité voir vincent
grass vers 18h15 en présence de mon
directeur de cabinet françois blouvac et
du responsable sécurité et sûreté le
supérieur hiérarchique de 20 centres
azpiri barratier immédiatement pour lui
demander des explications sur ce que
cette vidéo révélée pour information
vincent grass occupe depuis le 1er
juillet 2010 est un poste de responsable
adjoint sûreté sécurité au sein des
effectifs de la république en marche
en tant que non cadres et sous
l'autorité d'un chef de sécurité dans un
service de huit personnes qui a
notamment la charge de l'accueil la
surveillance des locaux de l'association
je tiens à votre disposition de se
présente madame monsieur le
co-rapporteur l'organigramme de ce
service lors de cet entretien vincent
kraz indiqué avoir agi en tant que
gendarme réserviste le premier mais à la
demande expresse d'alexandre benalla
avec il a indiqué être en contact dans
le cadre d'opérations réalisées elles
aussi en tant que gendarme réserviste la
115ème alors informé qu'il était chef
d'escadron gendarme de réserve depuis
1996 rattaché à l'elysée dans un cadre
extra professionnelles il a ensuite
confirmé que les faits étaient
intervenus en dehors de son temps de
travail la république en marche en
dehors de toute information de sa
hiérarchie et qu'il n'en avait pas rendu
compte
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce cadre je cite
ouvrez les guillemets gendarmes
réservistes par ailleurs employé de la
république en marche qu'il est identifié
par monsieur bruno roger petit porte
parole de la république de la présence
de la république
pour information cet entretien n'a duré
que quelques minutes puisque je
présidais un bureau exécutif à 18h30
devant effectuer le lendemain un
déplacement de trois jours dans l'eure
et loir du 3 au 5 mai j'ai demandé à mon
directeur de cabinet françois blouvac et
aux supérieurs hiérarchiques directs de
vincent crasse pierre-yves barratier de
le recevoir
le 3 mai le lendemain pour définir les
suites à donner ainsi bien que ces faits
se soient déroulés hors de son cadre de
travail et la république en marche j'ai
souhaité le sanctionner parce que je
considère grave ce qui s'est passé j'en
ai fait indiqué vincent kra ce que d'une
part son comportement lors du 1er mai
est en total décalage avec l'attitude
attendu des salariés
la république en marche et notamment
ceux chargés de l'accueil de la sécurité
du mouvement y compris en dehors de leur
temps de travail et d'autre part qu'une
telle attitude porter atteinte à l'image
du mouvement qui l'emploie dans la
mesure où les faits se sont déroulés
alors que vincent kraz on m'avait
indiqué qu'il intervenait en tant que
réserviste à la demande de monsieur
benalla j'ai souhaité prendre la tâche
du directeur de cabinet de la présidence
de la république pour connaître les
suites à donner et que la sanction
infligée à monsieur kraz soient liées à
celles retenues à l'encontre de monsieur
benalla un échange a eu lieu entre mon
directeur de cabinet et le directeur de
cabinet de la présidence de la
république à ce sujet et c'est sur la
base de cet échange que j'ai donc
notifiée le 3 mai par courrier à vincent
kra la sanction de suspension de quinze
jours du 4 au 18 mai inclus
depuis l'ouverture de l'enquêté
judiciaire j'ai adressé vendredi 20
juillet vincent crachin croyait lui
indiquant que la réplique en marche
lancé une procédure de licenciement à
son encontre fondés sur le trouble
objectif au fonctionnement de
l'association et l'atteinte portée à son
image aujourd'hui sur la base du rapport
établi par l'inspection générale de la
police nationale
j'ai pu constater qu'outre la faute
monsieur kraz ajouté le mensonge
puisqu'il n'était pas ni présents ce
jour en tant que gendarme réserviste ne
bénéficiait d'aucune autorisation pour
être présent il a été présenté aux
autorités comme un collaborateur de
monsieur benalla et je note que le
rapport de l'igpn précise que là encore
je cite alexandre benalla est accompagné
pour la circonstance d'une seconde
personne qu'il présente comme un
collaborateur en l'occurrence vincent
kraz le major misère ce qui ne connaît
pas monsieur kraz mais ne demandent pas
d'explication compte tenu du statut de
monsieur benalla représentant affiché
est reconnu comme tel par sa hiérarchie
de la présence de la république le
rapport de l'igpn établit donc
clairement que l'activité salariée de
vincent kra ce n'est en aucun cas lié à
sa présence ce jour là le général
bio-farina le confirme d'ailleurs lors
de son audition à l'assemblée nationale
quand il précise que je cite encore
monsieur kraz que j'ai eu au téléphone
pour lui dire qu'il ne reviendrait plus
à des 10 et m'a dit qu'il avait suivi
alexandre benalla de son propre chef
ce jour là
la vérité est unique et que la vérité
quand on la regarde
à un moment donné dans mon cas sur un
téléphone portable sur une vidéo
et quand on le regarde plusieurs
semaines après avec des images
décortiqué étudier expliqué et tous les
commentaires qui vont avec finalement
elle n'est plus tout à fait la même mais
ma vérité pour moi les tuniques au
moment où je prends connaissance de ces
faits je suis je j'interroge l'agent
monsieur kraz qui me dit intervenir dans
le cadre de fonction de gendarme
réserviste auprès de la présidence de la
république
à ce moment là je vous le dis et je les
assume mon regard n'est pas le même sur
un citoyen qui interviendrait dans la
rue par rapport à des forces de l'ordre
qui ce jour là avec la mobilisation de
1200 black blocks avec les conditions du
1er mai je veux pas y revenir que vous
connaissez bien avec les dégradations de
commerces de véhicules quand vous avez
une image de quelqu'un qui vous dit
j'intervenais et ça n'est pas le cas
mais moi l'information que j'essaie
j'étais revenait dans le cadre de mes
fonctions de gendarmes réservistes sous
l'autorité de la présidence de la
république
mon regard je vous le dis n'est pas le
même tout comme il n'a pas été le même
quand j'ai vu les images la vidéo suite
à l'interpellation par monsieur benalla
écrase de l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre qui étaient là le troisième
temps de vidéos et je pense qu'au vu ces
images
personne ne s'est dit il ya un problème
de violence policière il fallait
neutraliser quelqu'un qui avait un
comportement particulièrement agressif
vis-à-vis là d'une police autorisé pour
intervenir et donc je vous le redis
c'est dans le cadre d'un regard à un
moment donné sur un téléphone portable
de quelqu'un qui veut dire intervenait
dans le cadre de mes fonctions de
gendarmes et donc j'ai considéré que ma
responsabilité était d'informer sa
hiérarchie pour vérifier que ces faits
étaient connus et qu'ensuite il une
sanction
je précise d'ailleurs que le général bio
farina qui a exclu de la réserve
président de la réserve de l'as de la
réserve n'y a pas ce que la réserve de
la présidence de la république et qui a
remis à disposition
monsieur kraz aux gardes républicains
a pris une décision dès le 4 mai sur ce
sujet en aucun cas il ne m'en a informé
j'ai découvert cette décision et c'est
normal d'ailleurs j'ai découvert cette
décision en fait au moment de l'audition
donc voilà ce que je veux préciser c'est
que le regard que vous portez monsieur
le sénateur sur à juste titre sur ces
faits là ne sont pas les mêmes quand on
vous dit que la personne intervenait
dans le cadre de fonction de gendarme
votre réponse et subtile au fond vous ne
nous dites pas les forces de l'ordre
étaient débordés et monsieur kraz agit
en bénévoles auxiliaires du service
public de la police pour leur prêter
main-forte nous dit à ce moment là j'ai
la conviction parce que ce sont les
éléments qui me sont fournis qu'il
agissait comme gendarme réserviste de
l'elysée sous l'autorité de monsieur
benalla également de l'elysée et vous
n'êtes pas allé plus loin
c'est seulement ultérieurement que vous
avez compris que à la fois les forces de
police n'étaient plus de gendarmerie
d'ailleurs n'étaient pas débordés même
si elle était soumise à de très rude à
sauver et que le comportement des deux
hommes était totalement déplacé dans
cette affaire néanmoins vous estimez
quand même utile d'infliger une sanction
à monsieur grâce dans le même temps
alors est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
incohérence dans la réponse que vous
nous faites
non parce que dans mon esprit à ce
moment-là j'applique la sanction décidée
par son autorité c'est à dire avec le
parallélisme des formes des quinze jours
et donc c'est sur la base de la lettre
de sanction de monsieur benalla que nous
avons repris de la même façon quasiment
la même lettre pour sanctionner
monsieur kraz en précisant bien dans la
lettre je tiens à votre disposition
ça n'a pas été contestée par monsieur
kraz aucun moment qu'il n'intervenait
nullement dans le cas de ces actifs est
professionnel sans en avoir informé ni
sa hiérarchie ni personne j'obtiens
c'est peut-être à votre disposition et
briques merci beaucoup d
effectivement cela intéresse notre
commission madame jourda merci monsieur
le président je insiste également sur ce
point et ma question sera peut-être
assez subjective mais dans la mesure où
vous avez trouvé ce comportement
choquant tout le monde a trouvé ce
comportement choquant et tous ceux qui
se sont exprimés sur ce point et qui
toujours pas nécessairement vos ennemis
mais plutôt vos amis n'ont pas eu
d'épithètes assez forts pour qualifier
le comportement des uns et des autres
c'est à dire de monsieur védrine
monsieur kraz le premier mais il n'y
avait il pas à craindre une crise
politique qui d'ailleurs est avéré
aujourd'hui du fait que vous ayez
conserver en vous rend une personne qui
était capable de se livrer à un tel
comportement qu'ils soient ou pas
gendarme réserviste car je suis monsieur
le président sur ce point l'explication
est subtil de la comprenons mais elle
est subtil et elle ne passe pas
facilement dans l'opinion est en réalité
aujourd'hui ce qui se dit ce qui
s'entend et que monsieur benalla et
monsieur kraz n'ont été démis de leur
fonction des types définitivement
c'était vous vous êtes séparés d'eux et
de lui s'agissant de monsieur kraz que
parce que l'information est devenue
publique
cette sanction est elle véritablement
adapté ses général alors je ferai une
correction sur la cause de la sanction
de la procédure de licenciement qui est
liée à la mise en examen et l'atteinte
portée à l'image parce que en droit du
travail
le comportement en fait de monsieur kraz
en dehors de ses heures de travail
n'aurait pas été une cause réelle et
sérieuse de licenciement
et c'est vrai que sur la base de ces
éléments là au delà de mon sentiment
personnel qui n'a que peu d'importance
endroit j'étais dans cette contrainte là
mais vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice
avec les éléments que nous avons
aujourd'hui évidemment mon attitude
aurait été différente mais je vous le
dis la vérité si elle est unique elle
n'est pas forcément perçu de la même
façon en fonction des éléments que nous
avons est que j'avais à ce moment là
dans le rapport de l'igpn il est indiqué
que monsieur kraz et n'a pas été comptés
la présence de monsieur crâne n'a pas
été contestée lors le 1er mai compte
tenu du fait qu'il avait été présenté
comme un accompagnant d'une personne qui
s'affichait qui était reconnu comme
compte comme membres de la présidence de
la république
cela pose un problème sur la prééminence
de la présidence de la république
puisque à partir du moment où la
personne a été présenté avec ce statut
rien n'a été vérifiés et on l'a laissé
faire
qu'est ce que vous en tirer comme
conséquence politique sur la place de la
présidence de la république dans nos
institutions
qu'est ce que vous en tirer comme
conséquence sur ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour éviter que cela puisse se
reproduire avec simplement un affichage
qui contribuent qui en fait n'est qu un
passe droit et est ce que vous ne pensez
pas que par rapport au débat que nous
avons pu avoir l'année dernière au
moment de la discussion budgétaire sur
des cabinets ministériels qui étaient
réduits parfois un minimum qui les
empêchait de fonctionner correctement
par rapport à une présidence de la
république qui prend de plus en plus de
place est ce que ces événements vous
conduisent à faire évoluer vos positions
sur la place de la présidence de la
république dans nos institutions et sur
la manière d'encadrer sa prééminence
oui c'est une question importante
la maladie du pouvoir dans tous les
temps et sur tous les continents ç'a
toujours été l'abus de pouvoir c'est
pour ça qu'on a inventé les
constitutions monsieur le délégué
général
sur la question de la vérification de
l'habilitation je n'ai pas à me
prononcer sur ce sujet mais j'ai
effectivement lieu comme vous l'anomalie
constatée dans le rapport de l'igpn sur
les conséquences à en tirer d'abord les
conséquences on va dire organisationnel
igpn fait des préconisations j'ai pu
noter que le ministre de l'intérieur
avait retenu la totalité des
préconisations avait demandé qu'elles
soient mises en oeuvre notamment sur la
question du statut d'observateur
ensuite je crois que vos propos m'amène
à une question politique sur les
conséquences politiques vos propos
d'ailleurs sont une interprétation
politique d'une situation
elle vous appartient je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit dans ce cadre là que je
puisse vous y répondre mais peut-être
plutôt sedan un débat que nous pourrions
avoir dans d'autres instances ce que je
sais c'est que au fond vincent kraz
était un chargé de mission à la peu
alexandre bédat était un chargé de
mission identifiés comme tels à la
présidence de la république et qu'il a
eu un comportement individuel
inacceptable qui ne remet en aucun cas
en cause la présence de la république et
la façon dont le président de la
république exerce son autorité
merci de cette réponse monsieur françois
noël buffet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le délégué général
nous avons appris que pendant sa peine
de suspension
monsieur benalla avaient été rémunérés
est ce que monsieur kraz par
parallélisme des formes
l'at il été pendant cette même période
et ma deuxième question monsieur voyez
pas que la question soit malicieuse
c'est une question de fait n'est ce pas
important ça me semble-t-il
et puis monsieur
benalla a fait l'objet d'une
rétrogradation qu'en est-il également
toujours par par alison parallélisme des
formes de monsieur vincent kraz merci
monsieur le délégué général
il a fait l'objet d'une suspension de
ses fonctions entre le 4 et le 18 mai
elle était signifié par lettre
recommandée avec accusé réception et il
n'y avait pas de suspension de salaire
alors sur la rétrogradation
là je vais être un peu
oui
et donc je vais je vais préciser que
pour ce qui est de la rétrogradation les
fonctions de monsieur crabes
ce n'était pas tout à fait les mêmes que
celles de monsieur benalla donc il
m'était difficile de réorganiser par
contre je le dis tout à l'heure il n'a
plus fait aucun déplacement extérieur
dans ce cadre là et de toute façon il
n'a jamais eu l'occasion de
m'accompagner dans mes déplacements
contrairement à ce qui est écrit dans la
presse ce matin ma sécurité personnelle
est assurée par mes officiers de
sécurité et je voudrais préciser quand
même sur ce sujet qui est souvent un
sujet de fantasmes que je crois que
toute femme et tout homme politique qui
ont fait l'objet d'un accompagnement
pour leur sécurité savent que ce n'est
un plaisir pour personne et que personne
ne revendique d'avoir le plaisir d'être
accompagné par des femmes et deux hommes
armés j'aimerais vous préciser que j'ai
fait l'objet d'une tentative d'attentât
qu'un réseau terroriste a été démantelée
que cinq personnes sont actuellement
toujours en prison et que quand vous
apprenez que ces gens vous ont suivi
dans votre commune à forcalquier pour ce
qui me concerne avec la volonté de vous
égorgez vous dit que finalement on
serait mieux sans officier de sécurité
dans un système où nous n'aurions pas
besoin mais je précise au delà de cette
remarque là qui avec ma sécurité n'ait
assumé que par les officiers de sécurité
qui sont à ma disposition du ministre
que je suis le crash n'a jamais été en
charge de ma sécurité et donc il n'avait
pas besoin de connaître d'évolution sur
ce sujet merci de cette réponse monsieur
kerrouche
merci monsieur le président je voulais
intervenir à la fin mais puisque vous me
donnez la parole maintenant je vais
demander à monsieur le délégué général
monsieur questionnaire vous avez vous
avez déclaré la semaine dernière que les
oppositions étaient la coalition de ceux
qui n'aiment pas l'état des séditieux de
ceux qui veulent une république
affaiblie avides de têtes qui roulent
je voulais savoir si vous aviez été
rassurés cette matinée par votre
audition au sénat
quant à nos quant à nos attentions vu la
qualité de nos débats et vous rassurer
dans le sens que nous allons tous nous
avons tous la même volonté d'aller dans
une transparence pour la pour la
république sur ledit général solutionner
j'espère que vous avez préparé comme moi
cette audition et que vous avez pu en
allant sur mon compte facebook lire la
totalité du texte dans lequel je parle
qu'il ya eu un rassemblement d'opposants
virgule et je j'imagine que vous classer
dans cette catégorie au moins
l'assemblée nationale le groupe
politique auquel vous appartenez est
membre d'un groupe d'opposition virgule
de séditieux virgule et j'ai donné un
certain nombre d'éléments je ne
considère pas que tous les opposants
sont des séditieux bien au contraire
je tiens à vous rassurer si vous avez
pensé cela et urbanité que nous vous
connaissons me faisais spontanément
exclure cette hypothèse mais il faut
reconnaître que la phrase était ambiguë
mais l'interprétation de la virgule est
important de vous en remercie alors
madame traîne les oui merci monsieur le
président ce délégué général ma question
portait en fait sur l'effectivité de la
sanction mais néanmoins j'ai une petite
question complémentaire précédemment
vous étiez membre actif du parti
socialiste et vous ne pouviez bien
évidemment pas ignorer le la la sangle
pas la sanction mais disons lorsque
monsieur montebourg était ministre et
que monsieur benalla travailler pour lui
que suit un comportement non
recommandables monsieur montebourg lui a
demandé de ne plus travailler pour lui
dans un souci de transparence mais
également de sécurité
à aucun moment n'avez vous parlez
converser signalé cette situation
lorsque monsieur bénard a été recruté
dans le cadre de la campagne de monsieur
macro et ensuite à l'elysee monsieur
castaner sous réserve de me tromper je
crois que personne ici et compris ceux
qui sont restés au parti socialiste pour
reprendre votre marque lumière n'avait
entendu dire que monsieur montebourg
aurait demandé ou virer son chauffeur
voilà donc c'est une information qui est
tombé deux pics monsieur montebourg
indiqué mon statut de membre du parti
socialiste sans aucune responsabilité
nationale du parti suisse ne m'amenez
pas à connaître de ce genre de décisions
d'un ministre du gouvernement donc
m'avait interrogé sur le fait de savoir
si je ne pouvait pas ignorer
je vous dis je l'ignoré totalement si
ç'avait été le cas si j'en avais eu
connaissance je pense que j'en aurais
préféré
merci monsieur le délégué général
monsieur le fichier oui monsieur le
président monsieur le délégué général
je crois que ce qui nous interroge tous
ces notions un petit peu d'amitié
complice qu'il y as entre monsieur
benalla messieurs kraz et qui aboutit au
fait qu'ils se donnent rendez-vous
quelque part le jour du 1er mai pour
être l'un de savate heures l'autre rien
du tout observer les comportements vont
un petit peu commencé où les
manifestations puissent devenir un
terreau plan sans que jamais personne ne
les interrogent et on arrive à une
situation de brutalité qu'on constate
qu'on a vu tout sur les vidéos
et là encore personne ne les interroger
depuis le début d'une audition en fait
la constante c'est que chacun nous dit
mais en fait on ne savait pas ce qui
veut dire qu'on peut circuler comme ça
entre les services entre les mailles du
filet pour arriver à des actions qui
sont extrêmement graves et la question
que je voulais vous poser c'est de
savoir si au sein du mouvement elle rêve
vous aviez été amené à intervenir au
service ou votre environnement pour
savoir s'il n'y avait pas d'eau
autre personne qui pouvait associer à un
moment ou un autre à ce type de
comportement qui s'inscrit en fait dans
une forme de dap unités liées à la fête
qu'on y est on est défendu par tout sauf
à ça qu'on n'est pas attaquable
puisqu'on étant des services du
gouvernement et de l'elysée
monsieur le délégué général question
subjective que vous posez laquelle je
vais répondre par l'objectivité d'abord
de la révision du statut d'observateur
on voit bien une anomalie dans la façon
dont monsieur benalla c'est considérer
invités et dont beaucoup ont considéré
qu'il l'était et puis le fait qu'il
vienne avec une personne qui n'est pas
du tout est vanité qui présente jusqu'au
20 collaborateurs et que ça suffise pour
que personne n'ose dire vous avez raison
c'est une anomalie et donc il est
important d'y mettre un terme je crois
que le rapport de l'igpn fait des
préconisations et que leur mise en
oeuvre de permettre de sécuriser ce soit
sur le deuxième élément vous évoquez
même des comportements qui au fond ne
font intervenir personnes j'ai en tête
les propos du préfet delpech qui dit
notamment pour ceux qui ne connaissaient
pas monsieur crasé qu'il voit intervenir
dans les forces de l'ordre que beaucoup
ont pensé qu'il était un policier et
qu'il était du coup légitime à
intervenir même si on peut conseil qu'il
y avait une disproportion dans les
conditions de son intervention
donc ça veut dire effectivement que tout
cela doit être revu pour ce qui concerne
l'interrogation que vous me posez pour
savoir si je me suis questionnée sur
sarce il y avait ce risque là de dérives
au sein de la république en marche
je ne les fais mais qu'a posteriori
parce que je ne pensais pas que ce
risque puisse exister mais évidemment
dès le lundi suivant le 18 juillet j'ai
réuni l'ensemble des personnels pour
leur dire deux choses la première c'est
que notre maison devait être une maison
transparente totalement transparente
notamment dans le cas de l' enquête
judiciaire qui pouvait amener à ce qui
est des opérations de justice qui soit
procédé dans cette maison et donc j'ai
indiqué à chacun qu'il fallait se
préparer à assurer toute la transparence
sur ces sujets et la seconde j'ai
interrogé pour savoir si effectivement
il y avait d'autres personnes dans la
maison qui pouvoir ce statut double de
gendarmes réservistes par exemple il
mettait précisé que nous
c'est la richard veut rebondir sur l'art
est une suggestion pour le travail de la
commission
merci obernoise aider à l'organiser
chers collègues mais j'en suis membre
il vous plait comme chacun d'entre nous
je suis là pour la magnifique viole la
liberté de la de la vérité et pour rien
d'autre et c'est la première fois qu'il
est fait mention de de l'écho de presse
suivant lequel monsieur arnaud
montebourg aurait eu monsieur benalla
comme chauffeur
arnaud montebourg était ministre du
développement du redressement productif
à bercy j'ai beaucoup de mal à imaginer
que quelqu'un était était chauffeur d'un
ministres de bercy sans être
fonctionnaire eh bien je crois que cette
remarque est judicieuse et je me propose
de me vanter à monsieur montebourg
bon pas tout si cette si cette
information est est réel essayez date de
l'important c'est ce qu'il a fait si
elle est si elle a effectivement si ces
faits sont établis ce qu'il a fait
ensuite à partir de là je remercie cher
collègue monsieur le délégué général
je voudrais apporter une précision parce
que j'étais imprécis il y a deux
personnes salariées de la république en
match qui sont engagés dans la réserve
de gendarmerie mais qui n'ont aucun lien
avec la réserve la gendarmerie de la
présidence de la république
donc je tiens les noms jeu peut-être pas
le dire publiquement mais je tiens les
noms à votre disposition mais du coup je
ne savais pas non plus mais comme j'ai
fait ce thione deux jeunes femmes qui
sont engagés mais qui sont des fonctions
administratives et qui sont à côté de
cela gendarme réserviste mais pas du
tout dans le cadre de la présidence de
la république ni même de la garde
républicaine je crois mais je vous
apporterai ces précisions là alors
monsieur campe le délégué général vous
avez dans votre déclaration préliminaire
fait pas de l'émotion et de l'importance
que vous êtes est créé à ce qui vient de
se passer
or parallèlement on a le sentiment que
parmi les autres responsables dans
marche des députés qui s'exprime
régulièrement ces jours ci on a
l'impression que la consigne est de
minimiser cette opération des éléments
de langage répétés autant que faire se
peut parle de 150 tonnes de mousse pour
15 g de savon
ça a sûrement été pensés quelque part
puisqu'on entend cette déclaration de
manière récurrente la manière dont
travaille dans kate a été conduit chez
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
par vos amis montre aussi la volonté
d'étouffer de limites et vous même dans
une formule assez lapidaire avait
qualifié monsieur ben à deux bagagistes
c'était effectivement au moment de la
coupe du monde mais enfin il faut quand
même rappeler
puisqu'on vous en face de nous ce mot
est ce qu'elle a est-ce qu'à la faveur
des investigations du parlement et
singulièrement de cette commission d
enquête sous l'autorité du président bas
et de ses rapporteurs qui ne cesse de
montrer les incohérences les
dérèglements de toute cette affaire est
ce que votre sentiment en tant que
déléguée générale de la république en
marche se modifie et puisque nous sommes
à la veille d'une réforme
constitutionnelle importante est ce que
vous considérez contrairement au
sentiment qu'on a pu avoir encore une
fois à travers toutes ces déclarations
que le rôle du parlement et
singulièrement celui du sénat est
important pour équilibrer faire en sorte
que lorsque des affaires d'état éclate
de la sorte et bien toute la lumière
puisse être faite par respect pour
l'opinion publique
alors la question s'adresse aussi un peu
au secrétaire d'état chargé des
relations au parlement la position dans
ma surtout alors monsieur le ministre
est délégué général c'est le président
vous êtes sentiment que certains ont
voulu minimiser
peut-être que je pars a le sentiment que
certains veulent exagéré quand on
qualifie ce dont nous parlons d' affaire
d'état
mais tout cela est subjectif vous venez
de parler d' affaire d'état je considère
dans mon référentiel à moins que nous ne
sommes pas dans une affaire d'état et je
n'ai pas l'impression de minimiser
vous voyez comme quoi le positionnement
politique selon où on se place peut en
avoir un regard différent
tout comme sur le fait que mme ait prêté
des propos d'avoir qualifié monsieur
benalla de bagagistes je voudrais
rappeler mes propos précisément et je
voudrais vous préciser que j'ai fait ça
le 19 juillet
je n'ai pas cherché à fuir une
quelconque responsabilité ni à minimiser
dès le 19 juillet je suis la première
personnalité de la réplique en marche à
me rendre sur un plateau télé pour
parler de cette affaire
et quand la journaliste m'interpelle
elle utilise un mot pour parler des
événements qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
de la gravité je la corriger
immédiatement voulu dire que je
considère que ces actes sont d'une très
grande gravité
et donc je n'ai jamais cherché à
minimiser je les fais dès le 19 juillet
un moment où assez peu de paroles
avaient été données et je vous le dis je
suis le premier responsable politique
aller sur un plateau télé pour justement
parler et évoquer la gravité est ma
première intervention et de corriger la
journaliste non pas pour lui donner une
leçon de sémantique mais pour qualifier
par proportionnellement à l'émotion qui
était la mienne sur la gravité de ces
faits et donc sur la question du
bagagiste quand la question m'est posée
dans une autre émission c'est sur bfm
rmc un matin je réponds je ne suis pas
l'employeur de cette personne je ne sais
pas quelles étaient ses missions j'ai
entendu dire qu'il était en charge de la
logistique et notamment des bagages vous
voyez votre propos mais qui a été
extrêmement relayée par certains qui
nous écoutent aujourd'hui est quand même
un tout petit peu caricatural par
rapport à ce que je dis surtout que
quand on sait que notamment le gspr dans
les voyages officiels est en charge
aussi de la logistique et des bagages
on peut considérer que le raccourci qui
a été fait par quelques années mon
propos est insultant y compris pour les
agents du gspr
[Musique]